[Musique]
tattoo de coutume par la radio ou à la
télé les journaux tout le monde enfin à
le truc mais oui ce matin chez lui au
précis m'attends à tout moment pas à
l'autre c'est foutu c'est que j'ai eu
trois ans lille à nantes aventure a
parlé aussi lui aussi long par un bon
oeil aussi parce qu'ils en pensent
d'ailleurs que tout le monde en corner
voici le nouvel épisode de tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec thierry ardisson
bonsoir d'illégaux portier
lucia
mais m
molly
un vrai public de télévision
gelé des stars du soir yvan attal
noémie lenoir
serge lama
non
henri lévy
les auteurs du scoop sur benoît d'elle
jacques gérault
arnaud gidoin
habitué des saab à taux zéro
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission pas comme les
autres vous connaissez le principe tout
le monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
vous connaissez les kiwos il en a vu
sort
quand on n'a pas d'argent on va pas dans
des cafés ses crimes
alors comment ça va dépouiller les gens
maintenant a même obligé maintenant aux
débutants 7 d'or comment tu te la pètes
tressé il est vendu le 7 d'or ça y est
comme son équivalent on peut faire mieux
encore le schéma cent mille balles le 7
d'or 68 val d'or et 10 mille balles
soutien gorge de talia mais c'est vrai
que tu as fini à temps c'est infini est
alors plus les dents plaidant que vous
avez envoyé directement ça fait 285
mille francs pour michaël blanc bravo et
merci pour lui et puis hein
il parait il paraît que le président
chirac commença à s'intéresser à son
sort donc jacques on compte sur toi pour
le faire sortir de là avant les
élections sinon on votera pas pour toi
la politique alors quelques emails
laurent arthur cas tucci de tirana en
albanie nous annonce la fondation d'une
association baptiste à tirana est sûre
ça manquait la balle à tirana ils font
des associations baptiste joël de
créteil dit qu'il serait peut-être bon
de séparer les bassistes des arts dit
sonia le bon grain de l'ivraie
[Applaudissements]
comme jusqu'alors que tout le monde soit
lui-même peux t on va pas le faire ce
soir avant banon était si on les bat
fils se désagrège un peu en fin
d'émission
je décris partie john hardy sonia c'est
marrant quand il commençait bien alors
d'autres email concernant tv5 que
laurent de vancouver au canada
qui dit tv5 a diffusé les 7 d'or une
semaine après le tout le monde en parle
qui précédait les 7 d'or en faut dire à
tv5 le faire attention je connais qui
dit on on finit par croire aux voyages
intertemporelle avec tout ça e-mail de
luanda luanda capitale 2 je ne sais pas
attends luanda je ne sais pas
il regarde y'a pays de l'est non on ne
souffle pas on regarde tout le monde en
parle à luanda capitale de l'angola lolo
alors leur sexe magouille et culture
chrétienne la laon ce soir ça va être la
170e trois là vous êtes parti pour jouer
800 fois là non ben en tout cas on est
parti pour jouer au moins 500 fois avec
la tournée ouais
comment on fait le lot je me souviens
plus à pour la promo c'est simple
donnez moi je suis déjà allé deux fois
nommé moi une bonne raison pour gérer le
troisième fois ça change tous les soirs
il ya des gens qui sont venus 4,5 fois
il ya des gens qui sont fans qui emmène
des amis et qui ne se remet bien de pas
après pas ce que ça change tous les
soirs et puis un truc drôle on peut le
regarder plusieurs fois et s'est marié
plusieurs fois dont pas mal pas mal
vendu non voilà quoi donc c'est au
gymnase europe afrique
[Applaudissements]
vous savez une tradition dans cette
émission c'est de diffuser chaque
semaine les meilleurs moments de
l'émission précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde a parlé
arrive pas concevoir qu'il y ait des
meilleurs moments quand je ne suis pas
dans l'hémicycle apparu qui me fait bien
mal en tueur je vais quand même regarder
tomber sauf et maman ça veut dire quoi
annie aime les sucettes à l'anis
j'ai passé les gloss moi je répondrai
tout simplement que c'est très très bon
les sucettes à l'anis voilà tu m'en
donnes coach omnium
za d'andurain quand même moi parce que
j'étais pour le loft donc je te le dis
d'autant plus avant longtemps mais shan
life as we puisque je com
la chanson de faire et j'aime bien ma
soir pour voir passer les cons donc là
je les avais sommes encore soir trois
ans au spatial préféré partir avec laure
saint clair qu'il va nous rejoindre tout
à l'air d'aller à anne sinclair ou bob
sinclair leur sinclair alors 5 l arrêter
le porno en même temps je vous le dis
bonjour en scrabble à qui empruntent
auriez vous le plus volontiers son
cerveau pour une greffe me dites pas
loana
non non j'ai le cerveau j'aime beaucoup
ce que vous haïssez dans la chanson
le côté il faut qu on m'a dit vous êtes
un vieux vrai q vous attendiez ce sens
il viendra un jour oui vous lancez un
appel parce que ça vous savez on a marié
larusso 1
c'est peut-être meilleurs trucs que vous
ayez je voulais partir il est saoul il
est avec lara fabian le de masse turbo
pardon masturbe l'euro vous trouvé ça
très bien mais auxerre est amusant on va
essayer de s'y retrouver c'est un jeu
faut prendre ça comme un jeu a mis
d'accord ouais 3 euros 3 euros c'est la
prochaine défaite de l'olympique de
marseille
alors quand vous avez été nommé ministre
97 vous êtes fait une grosse gaffe
énorme vous en souvenez de ça et oui
alors là ce qui est génial c'est
qu'elles sont halal chirac quand tu fais
sa gaffe
chirac lui du bon jean fred août et vous
avez fait une connerie
1 c'est pas grave moi j'en ai fait noter
regardez je suis encore là de 30
si vous étiez un terroriste jésus-christ
est ce que vous préférez une femme qui
baisent bien mais qui était infidèle ou
une femme qui baisent mal mais qui est
fidèle
j'ai la chance d'avoir les deux je veux
dire les deux sait caresser par
quelqu'un qui vous répugne ou battu par
quelqu'un qui vous aime c'est les
questionnaires c'est vous qui les fait
c'est simon à paris
le geste
ces gens préparent mais je suis en
gohelle
alors il ya un autre bon moment dans
l'émission c'est le blind thèse ce soir
en l'honneur de serge lama le blind
thèse sera consacré au chanteur et aux
chanteuses qui ont des noms d'animaux
c'est normal alors pour arbitrer ce
blind test gens là bas c'est ouais sur
le tas sierre et joe cocker ouais
j'appelle effectivement j'appelle un
homme dessus de tout soupçon
accompagné par ses deux juges de touche
voici ma j'avais les bordés
m
je vais
ça fait du bien de voir écrit habillées
elles sont bien comme ça bonjour bonjour
toi ça va oui bien alors philippe le jeu
idiot ce soir c'est quoi alors il ya un
gros dilemme parce que il est ce que ce
soir c'est le chiffon me ou alors le
caillou ciseaux et papiers et puis le
presque depuis joue bien sûr parce que
depuis je le puis jour c'est à dire quoi
ces conneries c'est à dire que tu es un
à la figure alors on y va donc didier
[Musique]
attention j'arbitre à trois chiffres
omis vous donner le signe hockey didier
mes ciseaux
hier
dommage
suis je
la gare où je sais
mais c'est tout à l'heure pour le high
tech petite allia peut tricher il ya un
email il demande votre tour de poitrine
combien suite aux problèmes test ok
merci tagliani institutions
et maintenant la femme d un sou le corps
les autres 1 à 10
2 on s'est fait quand c'est pas nous
voici yvan attal
yvan attal deux cent mille entrées
france en cinq jours c'est énorme
peut-être je me rends pas quand c'est
énorme de cent mille entrées ma femme
est une actrice donc le film que vous
avez réalisé où vous jouez avec votre
femme l'actrice charlotte gainsbourg est
un succès et ça se fête
je vous demande de vous arrêter bien
yvan bravo donc 200 milles en 35 jours
c'est énorme
alors dans ce film est aussi terrance
tarp noémie lvovsky laurent bateau
lionel abelanski et ludivine sagnier
voilà alors je fais tout l'allicine
toute façon c'est ça qui est génial on a
juste ouais c'est bien on a juste à
faire comme ça comme les chiens
l'arrière des voitures fait comme ça
voilà c'est ça qui est génial
donc c'est une comédie populaire de
qualité c'est comme ça qu'on appelle un
élégante on y est grande avec du style
absolument c'est difficile ce genre de
film et c'est rare donc c'est d'autant
mieux pour vous parce que il y en a pas
souvent
et puis surtout je dirais pour un
flemmard comme vous que vous êtes un
sacré costard quand même nom yvan
c'était la première fois que j'avais
autant de travail de ma vie je me suis
découvert d une énergie dingue c'est
encore plus dur quand on est paresseux
mais oui parce que les mecs bosseur ils
ont pas de mérite à y arriver
moi je me suis levé pour la première
fois de ma vie je me suis couché tard
pour la fin de ma vie quand je devais me
lever tôt le matin c'était un boulot
j'ai sous-estimé
quand on est acteur on sous estime le
boulot que c'est un metteur en scène
vraiment c'est ce qui m'a surpris
pourtant ça faisait dix ans que je
faisais du cinéma et vraiment je
m'attendais pas à ce que cette somme de
travail
voilà vous étiez les deux en plus
acteurs réalisateurs ludacris marie
taille des médias le principal ça fait
beaucoup
avec non seulement flemmards mais
hypocondriaque en plus un très
hypothétique ça c'est fou parce que par
exemple quand il fait des analyses
soient des radios soient des analyses il
les fait deux fois ce qu'ils y si des
fois il ya un labo qui se trompent
l'autre enjeu terrifie ce qui est
marrant en revanche c'est que pendant le
film j'ai eu aucune crise de rien n'est
pas été malade etc
mais dès que je me suis arrêté de
tourner ça a commencé le transfert de
du cerveau du matin effectivement je
vais faire des scanners quand je fais un
scanner géant j'en fais deux tranches et
là je me suis mis à lire m
ah oui mais ça prend du temps d'être
malade tout le temps comme ça va falloir
les toubibs et tous non mais oui oui ça
prend une surtout quand on les voit en
double alors je vais faire le pitch vous
voulez non je viens dans le pitch est
simple 1 c'est yvan qui est reporter
sportif donc il n'est pas acteur c'est
très important parce que c'est ça
explique beaucoup de choses dans le film
si vous avez été acteurs soient pas été
bien c'est juste que je voulais pas
laisser les spectateurs à la ramasse sur
un écran de ce qu'on raconte le fait
qu'il soit par hector c'est quelqu'un
qui connaît pas vraiment ce métier dont
il ya à peu près comme tous les
spectateurs
il pénètre dans ce métier comme la dame
le personnage ali est jaloux voir parano
ouais il vient finalement moi je le
trouve totalement lucide 1 il a raison
sa femme c'est un mec au cinéma pour de
faux mais elle se fait quand même
tripoter c'est un peu on voulait
préparer pour vous aussi là alors un
jour donc il tombe sur un fan un peu
lourdaud qui lui prend la tête en
voulant savoir ce qui se passe vraiment
au cinéma qui veut dire enfin ta femme
voilà quoi quand et la poêle avec un mec
quand il se roule une pelle c'est pour
de vrai quoi qu'il en soit c'est pour de
vrai ouais ça c'est parce que moi je lui
explique que c'est pour de faux
il lui s'obstine en me disant bon moi
même j'ai eu la gaule en regardant ta
femme à l'écran hier donc j'imagine
l'acteur est donc là yvan vous vous
péter les plombs et d'autant plus que
charlotte pas retourner à londres avec
terrine stop
pendant longtemps que je veux dire c'est
un tournage à l'étranger elle revient
pas tous les soirs et ses bas quand
quand on tourne quand sa femme et à
l'étranger on l'a pas sous la main donc
on a des angoisses quand on a ce genre
de conversation avec ce type au café et
qu'on commence à avoir le le ver dans la
pomme c'est encore plus angoissant
d'avoir sa femme et l'étranger qui
tourne avec un acteur charismatique
séduisant qu'est ce qu'on fait on prend
leur star et on va la retrouver tout de
suite sur les clashs magnéto serge enfin
pour un con j'en ai vu des films quand
ils s'embrassent ils s'embrassent
ils se roulent des pelles et east ont la
langue dans la bouche quand même me dis
pas que c'est pas vrai je reviens pas de
somme et que je te connais pas depuis 10
minutes et tu me parles comme ça je vais
pas te faire chier mais je te juste un
truc que je trouve incroyable quand même
un mec flingué notre monde attend cette
intrigue
je t'explique ok ok mais qu'il a un
revolver
toi tu crois que ça va revenir mais
c'est un faux revolver ya pas de balle
dedans mais qui fait sortir et autres en
fassent effet souvent mourir on lui met
du faux sang mais en vérité le maquis
pas mort lucien attends je suis pas
débile ou pas comparaître domec qui se
flinguer deux autres qui se roulent des
pelles monde mais qui se répète c'est
dégueulasse mais non je veux dire avec
une nana je peux pas comparer cesser
leurs vrais bouche alors leur vraie
langue ça rien à voir avec des flingues
déjà hier soir dans la salle j'avais la
trique t'imagines acteurs la gaule qui
de la voir bon je te jure c'est un truc
que je trouve incroyable
enfin moi je pourrais pas
quand on soir manade fils d'afrique
jeter de l'eau chaude le bien cap et moi
tu es à tauriac ça ça fait tâche et que
ça ne va se trimballe à poil dans le
film tu vois juste ça juste le fait que
tout le monde puisse la barre après ça
c'est pas faux ça hein c'est vraiment
elle s'attache que ça me fait ch
[Musique]
ok d'accord tu le prends mal ça
m'intriguait c'est tout bon maintenant
certain c'est que tu veux je te le
répète ça me fais pas chier tu te
demandes instruites au sénat il est
gentil et dans la scène avec lionel
abelanski économie l'hotsky alors noémie
lvovsky qui est une réalisatrice en fait
que pas devenir bloqués c'est formidable
la maîtrise est incroyable alors elle
est l'héroïne d'une histoire dans
l'histoire c'est votre soeur dans le
film elle est mariée avec un goal sur un
non juif et ils s'étripent sans arrêt
sur le fait de savoir s'il faut qu'ils
fassent circoncire l'enfant qui vont
avoir ensemble et alors il ya une scène
absolument génial c'est qu'à un moment
ils sont réconciliés et lui fait une
pipe sous les bras et lui il est là il
est allongé comme ça il fait c'est bon
le prépuce 1 et là tu vas la tête de la
filiale recommence à s'énerver c'est
vraiment drôle c'est un film que ce
serait drôle et pas une vraie pipelette
jusqu'à 100 du on sait pas ce qu'ils
avaient sous les draps mais il a l'air
d'avoir un sourire lui alors au faîte
charlotte qui était notre invité
récemment à refuser de répondre à cette
question votre votre fils belle île
circoncis ou pas voilà pourquoi la
refuser je sais pas oui les circoncis
circoncis ouais comme son père comme son
père
dans tous les cas charlotte elle est
radieuse dans ce film allez allez pas
nous y est allée elle est souriante avec
glamour on l'a rarement vu à l'écran
comme ça c'est à dire pas torturé avec
les cheveux propres
vous avez fait ben en fait
moi j'en avais effectivement marre de la
voir comme ça au cinéma à la maison à la
les cheveux propres ailes et souriante
elle est gentille et j'avais envie
j'avais envie de la voir comme ça j'en
ai marre qu'on qu'on l'appelle à chaque
fois qu'on a besoin une cosette au
cinéma quoi alors terrance tout est
parfait alors vous dites
évidemment si je les prie brad pitt à la
place de terre enstone y aurait pas eu
ce film parce qu'on n'aurait pas compris
qu'elle se bat repas avec lui
directement souci terme saint-philippe
pas mal non plus il ya des filles qui
crevait les yeux il est vieux voilà
quand même quoi
non c'est sûr que si ça avait été un
jeune gars beau etc
il n'y avait pas de film alors quand on
vous demande si autobiographique vous
dit que non évidemment vous dites je ne
sais pas vraiment autobiographique mais
j'ai pris des petites scènes comme ça de
la vie pour les mettre dans le film
enfin quand même charlotte nous raconter
c'est exact et plein de trucs en même
charles elle nous a raconté que dans
love et cetera de marion vernoux iv
berling est temps qu'il y avait rien
entre berling et elle vous étiez super
sympa et curling via un coup après le
tournage avec lui et tout ça est que
après des mois une love affair entre
berling elle j'étais quand même moins
sympa oui c'est vrai c'est vrai mais
aussi
il m'est arrivé d'en de faire un film
d'aller tourner un film à l'étranger de
rencontrer l'actrice avec qui je vais
avec qui je vais tourner et pourrait la
trouver si séduisante que ça et au
moment où les houles et où les scènes de
séduction et les scènes d'amour sont
arrivés la gaule au cinéma on maîtrise
pas les érections assez sympa façade on
hésite mois il s'est rien passé
j'aime beaucoup elle dit que pire
qu'embrasser pire que se retrouver au
lit avec un mec
en fait c'est vrai c'est l'état d'amour
dans lequel on se met pour jouer l'amour
regard le regardais les dépenses et même
d'ailleurs un moment vraiment des
raisons de flipper cela dit ça ici elle
a dit oui quand on joue l'amour
d'ailleurs une scène dans votre film que
vachement bien c'est un moment vous
arrivé par hasard à londres elle est
dans la caravane avec terrance tympanon
comprends bien ils sont en train de
baiser banques ont provoqué un truc quoi
nous est cher non mais c'est sûr que
quand on tourne il ya des choses qu'il
ya des choses bizarres sur les tournages
aux journées nos nuits ensemble oui on
oublie on oublie la maison quand elles
diront alors sérieusement l'un d'entre
eux galles pour un garçon sérieux c'est
le terrible quand même non comment on
fait qu'est-ce qui est érigée barney
avec une gonzesse toute la journée à
poil c'est ça que j'ai écrit cela était
jaloux il va parce que tout d'un coup
j'ai réalisé ce qui se passait dans ma
tête comme moi est ce qui est arrivé
les [__] qui tourne avec ma femme
qui était arrivée de forcer un peu la
main à sa femme pour qu'ils refusent un
scénario qui te faisait chier toi
honnêtement je n'ai jamais et on lui a
jamais demandé de tourner avec brad pitt
mais quand on est dans un lit à poil et
qu'ils vont 16 toute la journée
bon ben non on peut vendre
enfin ça peut arriver c'est de se dire
mais qu'est ce qui se passe là bas alors
après l'attaqué qu'elle devient du film
là dessus j'en profite pour moi la
question des dunes alors une seule
question et après on arrête quand on
fait semblant de bgc une gonzesse
bon on est sur l on fait semblant de
baisers au cinéma la queue en lamé ou
dans l'autre trou il ya tous les jours
mais c'est une question qu'est ce qu'on
fait est-ce qu'on se la fait scotch et
non on peut se la faire scotché sur la
cuisse en un an c'est scotché sur la
cuisse je balancerai pas mais je connais
un hacker qui sait scotché son poste à
faire scotché sur les classes de maître
entre les cuisses mais au bout d'un
moment on joue sinon bah je sais pas ça
dépend où est la caméra aussi quoi c'est
je sais pas ou alors on est vraiment
dans on fait n'importe quoi un peu voici
non ça dépend où la caméra mais a priori
la caméra et jamais
là où il faut vraiment en signant là
mais vraiment si la cam et 16 c est les
films pornos quand même qu'ils vont
chercher ça mais non mais c'est aussi
l'état à l'amour c'est aussi dans la
tête donc
donc c'est sûr que ça peut devenir un
petit peu excitant et à la gêne y'a le
malaise est bon c'est assez bizarre
parce qu'il arrive qu on s'abandonne est
con et j'accuse vraiment là aussi j'ai
entendu parler de certaines histoires
mais je tairai ce monsieur cinéma même
si ça se passe pas là ça favorise qui
peut se passer après quand on dit
journée terminée on n'a peut-être pas
forcément envie de rentrer tout de suite
oui sous la couette il va peut-être pas
dû payer un verre après quoi ça mais ça
favorise la pré tournage à dakar et
votre coupe résiste à tout ça depuis une
dizaine d'années une dizaine d'années
c'est fort quand même moi j'ai pas eu
tellement l'occase j'ai pas eu beaucoup
d'occasions
non ce qui est terrible empêcha pas à
tourner avec des diplômes voit mal comme
un mec à femmes au cinéma sur le copain
de celui qui se tape la balle et moi je
veux pas vivant yvan je vais pas vous
filer le bourdon
enfin c'est vrai quand même que vous
avez rencontré charlotte gainsbourg sur
un tournage c'est vrai donc si c'est
arrivé une fois ça peut arriver deux
fois et bien qu'il ça peut recommencer
non bien sûr que ça va commencer mais
sur six vit le chauffe pas trop
non j'ai pas trop de chauffer
yvan attal on va essayer de mieux vous
connaître
[Applaudissements]
alors vous êtes né en 1965 à tel aviv en
israël alors vos parents contrairement à
beaucoup d'autres c'est des pieds-noirs
et au lieu de venir en métropole en 62
quand l'algérie a été indépendante
ils sont partis en israël pourquoi je
suppose qu'à l'époque il était sionistes
juifs d'algérie sont barrées ils ont été
en israël
et vous savez quoi ouais vous avez été
conçu dans un kibboutz exactement dans
une conception collective
alors en fait vos parents ils restent
pas longtemps là-bas parce qu'en 67
quand vous avez deux ans il rentre en
france leur a pas plu même pas deux ans
je crois profiter tout petits sont
restés quatre cinq ans je crois qu'à
l'époque il y avait en fait énormément
de racisme entre sépharades et
ashkenazes on va dire entre ceux qui ont
fondé l'état d'israël et ils viennent
d'europe de l'est
exactement et les arrivées il y avait
quand même pas mal de racisme et du coup
j'étais pas si bien que ça en israël
donc ils viennent en france à créteil
là vous retrouver dans une hlm votre
père horloger et votre mère son boulot
c'était de s'occuper de vous ce qui
était un boulot à plein temps il faut
bien le dire
alors vous retournez de quelques fois
comme ça en israël après mais en fait
c'est quand vous tournez les patriots
avec rochant vous vous arriver un jour
dans une caserne qui avant était un
hôpital
et c'est là vous avez c'est fou vous
avez votre mère avait dit oui c'est
l'acte est né vous êtes tellement tourné
dans une
un matin j'arrive très très tôt dans une
dans une espèce de enfin s'était
transformé en caserne pour le film
c'était censé être des bureaux du mossad
et on me dit que c'était une clinique et
je suis dans cette ville où je suis né
d'ailleurs il ya faux et à côté tel-aviv
et à ce moment-là je me dis c'est que
c'est pas possible il n'y a pas pas une
grande ville et on me dit que c'était un
hôpital donc effectivement j'ai appelé
on m'a dit que c'était l'endroit où
j'étais resté assez étrange reste
étrange alors vocation précoce en cours
de mise en scène des lycées et
rapidement vous découvrez robert de niro
dustin hoffman al pacino votre modèle au
cinéma c'est le parent c'est pas
forcément le parrain mais mais quand j'y
réfléchis je crois que c'est un des
films qui m'a vraiment donné envie de
faire du cinéma et même aujourd'hui s'il
ya un tas de films que je peux
revendiquer que j'aime
il est ressortie en dvd ça faisait
quelques
année on va dire je n'avais pas vu et je
suis resté scotché à nouveau battu dijon
resté scotché alors quand vous dites à
vos parents vivent en attaque voulait
faire du cinéma ils sont pas inquiet
parce qu'il existe de toute façon il va
se décourager 1
c'est vrai que j'étais assez gt gt à ses
grandeurs donc j'ai dit que je voulais
faire des cours de mise en scène j'ai
commencé à faire des courts pendant que
j'étais en terminale j'ai abandonné donc
ils se sont dit ça nous faisait chier
enfin c'est pas que ça lui faisait chier
ça les inquiète et évidemment mon petit
juif il fallait que je fasse mes six
mois en tout cas des études je n'avais
pas pu faire et j'ai pas eu mon bac donc
je vais dans un cours de théâtre
et puis et puis ils sont pas forcément
inquiéter mon père me forcez quand même
à venir au magasin changer les piles des
montres vous avez à florange et au cours
florent
deux échecs au conservatoire alors voulu
dire qu'aller tous les petits bruns
ouais j'ai l'impression en tout cas les
années où moi j'ai passé c'est que c'est
quand même des grands blonds qui était
retenu au conservatoire ça a beaucoup
changé ma maman et puis les auditions
c'était bâclé le maquis vous donne 10
secondes pour faire un truc c'était
assez atroce je me souviens même de la
rue blanche que que j'ai que j'ai foiré
ça a duré dix secondes j'ai dit roy a
répliqué j'ai entendu merci
mais c'est fini quoi donc et au
conservatoire on va dire que ça a duré
dix secondes de plus est a priori on
arrive sur le plateau
et pas besoin de moi ouais alors là vous
faites une pièce sur scène avec des
potes qui s'appelle biloxi blues de neil
saimone vous faites le rôle d'un d'un
juif intello avec des petites lunettes
rôle de composition et vous êtes repéré
effectivement par eric rochant qui vous
fait jouer un monde sans pitié avec
hippolyte girardot
il ya la fameuse phrase dont tout le
monde se souvient ce film est génial un
monde sans pitié c'était un choc pour
tout le monde
tu vas arrêter de faire la moue le
milieu du salon coq est quand même une
phrase culte césar du meilleur espoir
masculin quand même dès le premier film
moi ces histoires ça va quand même et
ensuite voilà ensuite les deux films
suivants et consolide sa dose c'est vrai
c'est vrai ces deux échecs après les
deux films d'euros chance à eux
aux yeux du monde
avec charlotte gainsbourg et les
patriots certains marchés c'est un bon
fait pas marcher mais c'est dommage oui
c'est un bon voilà c'est des années
galères ouais
après un gros carton comme ça ces danses
et des années galère parce que parce que
j'ai pas parce que j'ai cherché aussi
j'ai refusé des films j'ai refusé des
films en plus qui ont très bien marché
donc je suis tombé dans un donc en fait
on n'a plus envoyé beaucoup de scénarios
enfin de quoi donc
donc c'est devenu un peu la galère ouais
là vous devenez un peu branleur à ce
moment là bas totalement bon leur choix
et je souhaitais plus rien c'est vos
journées avec charlotte
non c'est vrai vous lever tard dans
c'est vrai oui oui c'est ça on est
encore mais c'était bien en même temps
vous plantez un peu votre carrière
d'acteur ouais mais je fais je fais pas
exprès je me laisse un peu vivre en même
temps j'ai commencé à ces jeunes quand
même j'avais je sais pas quel âge avait
quand j'ai fait un monde sans pitié
quand quand on fait un film on prend un
bon petit chèque moi j'étais pas habitué
à gagner autant d'argent
j'ai passé mon temps à claquer mon
argent plutôt qu'à l'ére faire des films
c'est ça me convenait complètement
et puis je me suis remis quand il n'y
avait plus d'argent avec le banquier
très simple finalement voilà
mais
ils ont un talent vous êtes en train de
devenir une star
donc vous allez avoir droit à
l'interview alain delon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
légaliser les drogues douces vous trouvé
l'idée stupéfiante où vous trouvez
stupéfiant que c'est pas encore été fait
ils pensent que
enfin yvan attal pense que ce serait
bien maintenant de légaliser une bonne
fois pour toutes
votre conception du luxe c'est boire du
coca cola dans un verre en cristal ou du
petrus dans un gobelet en plastique
quitte à se la péter vraiment yvan attal
yvan attal est même beaucoup le petrus
même dans un gobelet en prestige en
plastique ensuite c'est finalement à
dire ça c'est une façon de battre mais
je sais pas je me suis adressé eelv ont
atteint s'est redressée il a ils avaient
ils vont avoir besoin mais pour lui
apporter un petit accoudoirs avez vous
le sentiment d'avoir le plus souvent
raté votre chance d'être un ou d
occasion de vous taire
ils vont être un peu vous demander de
avez vous le sentiment d'avoir le plus
souvent raté votre chance d'être un ou d
occasion de vous taire
est ce qu'ils vivent en interne est trop
con bon compromis
bras droit et il aura décidé de le faire
à la demande de passer à la question
suivante 5 pour atteindre ne veux pas
répondre devant elle ne veut pas répéter
souvent elles pensent qu'il a laissé
passer quelques chances mais bon c'est
on va pas se rendre sur ce sujet pour
vous le plus choquant c'est
l'interdiction des mariages homos ou la
banalisation des divorces hétéro ils
vont à ta leçon se sont fous un peu
aussi la différence au rêve c'est
qu'alain delon il avait surtout lui
ferait la différence hockey y parvenir
il va venir je vais tenir là ouais le
nom de mettre en page
question question commerce du sexe êtes
vous ils vont natale pour la turquie va
répondre
êtes vous pour la réouverture des
maisons closes ou la fermeture des
boîtes à partouzes yvan attal et pour la
réouverture des maisons closes et aussi
et pas du tout on va pas pour la
fermeture des voies comme ça y est bien
ce livre à canon il faudra bien la bande
originale du film
l'année de la crise
bande originale de brad mehldau mesdames
messieurs
j'ai la vitesse
à près de chez vous voilà et je reçois
maintenant noémie lenoir
noémie lenoir yvan attal
talât gaulle l'a très bien on vous a
tellement aimé
l'année dernière deux ans et demi qu'on
avait envie de vous retrouver de vous
revoir sa fille bien très bien merci
vous êtes toujours dans l'ange ans ford
c'est ça très genre toujours tout va
bien alors j'imagine que tout le monde
connaît la légende de noémie lenoir vous
la connaissez la légende de noémie
lenoir
alors c'est une légende courte et belle
noémie lenoir un jour va à
gif-sur-yvette dans un bureau de poste
pour acheter des timbres et une dame
s'adresse à elle y subit pas la ramener
sur ma mère excusez la bataille est donc
cette dame dit à notre ami noémie vous
devriez être mannequin
voilà et c'est une dame qui avait été
mannequin dans l' agence ford aussi
d'ailleurs 40 ans et voilà et alors
noémie est une fille modèle c'est normal
qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle pas ce film
ses études elle fini toutes ces études
et/ou et après ben voila vous devenez
mannequin et vous partez aux usa faire
un stage de coca y aller pour une
semaine et j'y suis resté deux ans et
maintenant je suis en france
ah bon sa vie pour toujours ah oui chez
sa maman qu'est la france
j'avoue j'avoue j'avoue et vous m'avez
manqué très content c'est vrai qu'on a
vu au café
[Musique]
jeudi
les jours
g
je souffre
je ne
[Musique]
son parent
bien
tha
[Musique]
non mais
oui
est ce que vous êtes sûr noémie est ce
que vous étiez à new york au moment de
du wall trade center hélas oui
ah bon oui j'habite chaînes gratuites
ouais ce qui en fait à 200 mètres des
toons towers ouais j'ai vu tomber en
fait sauf quand l'événement s'est passé
j'étais chez moi j'ai vu deuxième avion
arrivé et j'ai pas pu rentrer chez moi
pendant un mois
et quand je suis rentré bien il y avait
plein de cendres par tout ça sentait la
mort et j'avais une une vue sur les
twins towers zéro maintenant et j'ai eu
ça m'a vraiment fait mal
il faut dire aussi une chose c'est qu'il
s'est passé un truc très important pour
vous ici en france c'est que depuis
quand vous à paris vous avez fait un
film quand même oui celle-là du pot
cette noémie lenoir c'est incroyable
astérix deux événements dans votre vie
oui c'était vraiment drôle
une courtisane en faire ce qui est drôle
c'est que j'inclus l'aude on faisait une
pub pour du shampooing dans un studio à
côté il est allé voir chabat est en fait
j'avais fait un casting deux semaines
avant ouais je ne savais pas si j'étais
retenu et j'ai été voir alain chabat et
j'ai fait bon jour c'est parce qu'ils
avaient vous si vous avez vu ma cassette
je me présente je suis naïve et le noir
j'aimerais bien tourner dans votre film
et puis il a craqué complètement gelé
fait quoi
la sicile
alors qui veut trouver un boulot de
réalmont d'acteurs donc vous tourner
effectivement dans le nouvel astérix
avec depardieu avec clavier avec monica
bellucci
jamel debbouze et tout c'est génial
c'est vraiment bien c'est une bonne
expérience
bien sûr le premier film avec les grands
du cinéma c1
c'est ce qu'on attend d'eux plus à fish
69 vous connaissez le principe 1
noémie c'est vous qui me posais une
question les rôles sont renversés hockey
qui tu baises qu'est-ce que tu prends hu
c'est une des questions c'était trop
habitués aux gens qui te disais est ce
que vous m'aimez tibet ce qu'est ce que
tu prends alors je baise ma femme non
mais c'est bien on guérit toujours et je
prends des pétards voilà c'est tout
c'est bien puis un peu de champagne
alors tes parents ça va je leur achète
une maison c'est une fille modèle
j'ai acheté une maison pour un moment la
réunion mon père est en france et mon
frère est en france voilà je pense ça
fait un mois mais la famille passe avant
tout comme d'habitude alors des joies
problème oui ton petit copain américain
fini ouah
beaucoup d'heureux ça veut dire qu'il
était avec toi que pour la vue sur les
twins towers pourquoi ça parce que
qu'est-ce qui a merdé
je vais pas faire les pipots garçons
j'aimerais faire y fit pas là j'en fais
jamais je m'aime pas y'a pas moyen
on rallume et vous êtes vous êtes les
tops craquante tiens vous le dire quand
même
on va pas épiloguer quand vous êtes
venus ici pour la première fois vous
aviez dit à patrick bruel qu'il était un
petit peu pour vous le portrait de
l'homme idéal et depuis me parle de vous
et se sont revus avant je sais tout
s'est jamais revu il s'est vanté c'est
pas vrai média tout le monde quitte à
pechos1 by -5 mythomane l'a créée donc
tu dessines des gentils ce soit
maintenant ça suffit
alors vous dites le mieux avec les mecs
ça serait un bail de deux ans
renouvelable c'est pas mal dans les
filles
les mecs ont peur de vous draguez nant
je suis sûr moi ce que vous êtes grande
mesurait un mètre 77
ben c'est bon j'ai pas tellement de
poitrine mais bon ça fait rire mais les
mecs ont peur de vous draguez non c'est
pas qu'ils ont peur mais c'est que je
suis un peu froid avec un fil
d'entretiens un garçon qui sait surtout
qu'il ya plein de trucs dont elle est
plus sûrement bien le problème laurent
c'est quoi c'est qu'elle a un oeil
tatoué dans le dos quand vous savez
c'est patrick qui me l'a dit
je le sais c'est toujours bien sûr
personne ne me l'a dit je sais tout moi
vous savez que cette hausse est papa
il ya toujours plus bas fils derrière
moi canfin
noémie lenoir si vous ne répondez pas
une question c'est yvan attal qui répond
c'est le principe du joker merci génial
moi je suis pas non plus est-ce que par
amour
vous seriez prête à vous convertir à
l'islam je passe
ben oui ça va être dur
sur tes parents rassurez vous tout de
suite va pas de convertir à l'islam bien
nos amis le noir est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous faire refaire
les seins faire faire ça existe non non
non est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous mettre au troc
tueur
ah non si vous voulez mais pas vraiment
alors je pense pas qu'il pourrait me
dire j'accepterai jamais ça la maison
d'accord à la maison est-ce que par
amour vous seriez prête à faire cinq
enfants
oui en même temps par une famille de
foot
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
prendre 17 kg oui pourquoi pas la
question clotilde courau que les
habitués de cette émission connaissent
bien est ce que par un move ou seriez
prête à embrasser cent fois les
chaussettes sales de votre amoureux
alors c'est comme les jeux aux etats
unis quand ils doivent les chiens non
aux états unis à des émissions où elle
gagne environ dix mille francs et
doivent les chais des rambardes comme
dans le train
où manger des excréments des jeux sage
contre vous c'est re division bon marché
mad dominique thomas goisque on blague
qui m'a prêté jean pierre coffe 1
est-ce que par aman vous accepteriez
qu'il est une maîtresse non pas si vous
voulez mais vous étiez alors des gens je
change
j'oublie un fidélité si ça le rend
heureux d'avoir une maîtresse et main
qu'il a une maîtresse avec quelqu'un
d'autre mais pas moi en tout cas qu'il
est une maîtresse avec sa femme voilà un
droit en tout cas à les accords dont
vous seriez pas d'accord pour vivre à
trois avec la maîtresse c'est même pas
la peine que je vous pose des questions
n'ont ni à 4 c'est la question qui est
important est ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle
c'était attendu
mais oui encore
mais
mais bien peu ici qu'est ce que ça veut
dire mais tu serais prêt karamo à
devenir son esclave sexuelle
[Applaudissements]
en même temps si elles travaillent sur
cette émission a senti peu obligé alors
vous aurez alors il en est ce que par
amour vous seriez prêt à devenir son
esclave sexuelle sans problème sans
problème problème c'est un homme
ouais avant pour une femme c'est plus
dur d'être esclave sexuel quand même
c'est pas pareil c'est sympa et staff
sexuelles non mais il y avait un truc
qu'elle n'a pas envie de faire
ah c'est vrai
je
j'accueille maintenant serge lama
damien palestine
djama bonsoir bonsoir ça va donc noémie
lenoir
oui oui je sais un petit peu ces
spécialistes voila voila yvan attal qui
a fait ma femme est une actrice
oui voilà serge lama dont le dernier cd
s'appelle feuille à feuille
[Musique]
donc c'est un album entièrement consacré
aux cabanis serge lama comment ça va
bien alors après de longues années dans
le symphonique vous prenez le
contre-pied de tout ce que vous avez
fait et vous faites de l'acoustique du
minimaliste là subitement j'ai voulu
faire quelque chose de beaucoup plus
dépouillée et on est parti en tournée
donc avec des anciennes chansons dans un
système minimaliste mais surtout sans
son piano qui a changé beaucoup maviepro
musiciens son piano et sa dette publique
non non c'est pas le cas c'est pas le
cas il y avait beaucoup de public et pas
de cadeau jeff et l'océan indien
l'auxerrois oui j'ai fait la situation
voilà la maman de noémie et de la
réunion réunion ge à la voile alors ça
que je dis ça oui l'île maurice et le
québec
j'ai fait six semaines au québec où et
isabelle boulay il n'en j'aime ça je les
parfaites mais enfin j'ai fait que c'est
donc non non j'ai fait une chanson pour
elle mais non ça s'est arrêté là ouais
ouais c'est pas comme laurent gerra avec
souli avec oui alors les musiques ont
fait promo la sérieux les musiques donc
il ya yves gilbert vous êtes avec lui
depuis 67 ans a vécu
oui du travail a parlé je vois là depuis
66 alors ensuite parmi les musiciens qui
ont composé pour vous il ya christophe
leporatti nicolas manta zoo qui a
réalisé le disent d'ailleurs sylvain
liste et voila sylvain michel québécois
qui québécois rrq et avec lequel j'avais
écrit une chanson justement pour
isabelle boulay et c'est pour ça que je
connais sylvain michel beaucoup plus que
il avait le boulet ouais encore que je
connais mais isabelle quand même mais
pas à ce point là non je vous assure je
l'appelle boulet dans leur jeu
vous le direz vous êtes bien vu au
québec oui je pense mal vu au québec
parce que j'ai dit à une québécoise que
son accent se trouvait pas sa terrible
je reçois des lettres du québec
incroyable bah oui parce que c'est une
sale con général s'est mis sur un bel
accent les québécois simplement je
comprends que au lycée doit pas être
évident ouais parfois je peux vous dire
c'est très agréable d'être avec une
québécoise isabelle boulay se dire
étoile mal des québécois que
personnellement rien qu'avec ou sans
accent dakar alors on va parler des
paroles parce que vous avez un problème
vous qu'est le problème inverse de
julien clerc
je suis donc là on parle toujours de ses
paroliers on dit toujours etienne
roda-gil maurice vallet jean nil à bali
et c'est bon et on oublie toujours que
julien car il a fait quand même toutes
les mélodies de toutes ses chansons et
qu'elle le dit c'est énorme j'en ai
fièrement et vous c'est un peu pareil
serre que on oublie souvent vous avez
fait toutes les paroles de toutes vos
chansons quand même c'est peut-être
aussi parce que je fais partie de ces
chanteurs qui ont de la voix et qui
occulte beaucoup ce qu'ils chantent une
certaine manière on écoute le chanteur
et puis on en fait c'est depuis mes
débuts effectivement j'ai connu mes
textes mais ça c'est vraiment fort qu'on
comprend pas bien les parents à leur
reprocher un peu mais c'est pour ça que
j'ai fait ce disque car maintenant avec
trois musiciens on comprend tout voilà
au couteau puis je chante un peu moins
fort aussi voilà j'ai fait un effort
pour vous savez comment on fait serge
lama oui avec les petites mains la fava
les mimines noémie montrez-lui t'adore
fait un deux trois
feuille à feuille donc voila et le
single s'appelle quand est ce qu on fait
l'amour à ses tocs écrit les paroles
donc
quand est on sait
l'amour
on se parle et dalida
on se parlait de dieu
on se disait
un jeu
e
on s'est regardés ou pas
non s'appuyer autant
on s'agrippe et hopper qui étrangle et
donc qu'ils aient tout fait pour que
on s'accroche irons
j'écoute les paroles maintenant la wii
alors ben c'est pas c'est pas la plus
littéraire du disque il y en a d'autres
qui ne se jouera sur ma fille y en a
d'autres qui sont un peu plus littéraire
mais c'est ces jeux c'est voilà alors
inspiration toujours les femmes
oui enfin l'amour le couple
les rapports la nostalgie la nostalgie
aussi comme mais comme tout le monde j à
18 ans vous aviez écrit une chanson qui
s'appelait quand j'avais 15 ans quand
vous êtes vraiment le roi de nostalgie
parce qu'à 18 ans tu as une chanson qui
s'appelait quand j'avais 15 ans oui ceci
dit les beatles yesterday
il n'était pas tellement vieux non plus
c'est vrai je crois qu'on est
nostalgique très tôt à 15 ans au climat
chansons mais on va parler de vos 15 ans
justement
alors serge lama vous êtes né en 1943
oui vous êtes le fils unique de georges
et georgette chauvier et on va parler de
votre père parce que le destin de votre
père vous a marqué et finalement à
décider du vôtre d'une certaine façon
totalement mais c'est vrai alors votre
grand-père lui déjà le père de votre
père n'était pas quelqu'un de très
gentil hein
non non non c'était quelqu'un qui était
très violent qui qui buvaient et qui
taper mon père avec la avec sa ceinture
pour ça faisait malheureusement ça c'est
encore ça se faisait beaucoup à l'époque
et et mon père a été mis aux enfants
assistés il a eu une enfance assez assez
douloureuse mais c'est difficile
alors votre père quitte aubusson avec sa
mère à l'âge de 5 ans ils vont à
bordeaux
et quand il a 15 ans il s'inscrit dans
une société qui s'appelle la girondine
et rentre au conservatoire de bordeaux
il a grand prix et il peut pas chanter
sur scène pourquoi ça a été c'est une
douleur pour lui il parce que
normalement c'est comme au conservatoire
de paris quand on est comédien ont
généralement on jouait la comédie
française et puis normalement être qu'au
théâtre de bordeaux aujourd'hui jouer au
grand théâtre pis pour des raisons de
politique interne il n'a jamais pu le
faire et ça a été une de ses premières
blessures une de ses premières blessures
justement parce qu'on va voir y en aura
beaucoup donc il fait pas de scène il a
pas d'imprésario un moment il se dit je
vais changer de nom parce que c'est vrai
que chauvier bon pas terrible comme non
la preuve c'est que vous aussi vous en
avez changé la cause du prénom il
s'appelait georges j'aurais chauvier
janvier serge chevalier c'est pareil à
rennes comme ça c'est impossible il
faudra décide de simplement georges
gavarnie clavier même il avait essayé et
c'est que la vie à clavier georges
clavier puis ça c'était pas terrible non
plus les gavarnie gavarnie ça ressemble
un peu à guéthary donc il s'est dit et
ça va marcher
j'étais beau votre père sain-bel à maui
le très beau et coke selon les critères
de l'époque oui c'est un physique à
alain robert taylor
on appelait le prince charmant de la
chanson il décide de monter à paris vous
montez pas tout de suite vous restez un
an à bordeaux avec votre grand mère
et quand vous venez à paris c'est pas
drôle du tout vous retrouver tous dans
une petite chambre dans un meublé
et votre père votre mère votre grand
mère vous dans le 7e arrondissement rue
du vivier et votre père by fini au bout
d'un moment par décrocher un engagement
au delà des capucines
il a joué aux capucines dans une revue
c'est là que j'ai connu mes premières
danseuses nues et s'il a effectivement
que j'ai connu aussi nadine palier qui
fait est une amie à nous était assise là
ya pas longtemps madame de rothschild
voile souvient grande copine maiden rôle
nadine dan a dit elle jouait sur scène
nue avec le père de serge lama avait
fait l'un des premiers à voir les seins
de nadine talent y est voilà
j'adresse la joue un peu comme ça mais
c'est une [__] c'est une
merveilleuse fille elle a doublé bardot
dans certains sites non la poêle
il ya des films de bardot c'est 6 pouces
et nadine kiki qui pose pour la poitrine
et alors c'est à cette époque que va
naître votre vocation parce que voyez
votre père qui êtes aux capucines et
enfin si à l'olympia et un jour vous et
12 ans évite à votre père moi un jour
papa je serai en face oui parce que tous
les nouveaux tous les plus grands soins
commencé à passer à l'olympia c'est les
débuts de béco dont on n'imagine pas
aujourd'hui la carrière
un caillou gilbert c'était énorme énorme
on a cassé les premiers fauteuils pour
lui c'était d'ailleurs il n'était même
pas en vedette il était en américaine de
lucienne delille je me souviens de sa
scène eddie constantine a dit christine
star immense et je voyais ces noms
briller sur ce fronton et et je rêvais
alors vous voulez donc allé à l'olympia
et c'est l'époque que vous écrivez vos
premières chansons vous êtes fasciné
parce que votre père écrivait aussi il
était chantée par mariano bah oui c'est
là que le drame arrive votre mère en
fait c'était une minette au départ qui
était alors qu'il prétend beau chanteur
et elle est venue eu de cesse que de le
faire arrêter comme ça arrive assez
souvent
alors que
elle était très jalouse et puis c'était
terrible ce qu'on vivait lancé quand
même dans une toute petite marie
attachante elle me plait tous les soirs
j'entendais les engueulades mois donc
dans le livre c'est l'ailé scène mais
les scènes horribles qu'a lui faisait
pas ce qu'il aurait pu chanter mon père
il a refusé des tournées à cause de sa
jalousie des tournées de six mois
passent elles prétexté que c'était pas
métier certain mais sûr que pour manger
tous les jours c'était pas comme mes
gamins pas que ça il aurait pu vivre de
son métier mais en fait elle voulait pas
quoi ce qui est évident c'est histoire
c'est qu'elle a épousé parce que c'était
un chanteur et une fois qu'elle a été
avec lui et lui a interdit d'être
chanteur quoi c'est ben oui c'est ça
elle voulait le garder à l esprit
castratrice avec moi aussi à l'essai par
l'assemblée mais c'était en même temps
une femme elle même mais je veux dire
elle aimait mon père mais ces deux là
c'est de l'amour qui tue quoi ça l'amour
et je ne devrais pas retrouvé cette
époque là pour dire la vérité parce que
j'étais très malheureux pendant dix ans
je reprendrai tout voyez toute ma vie
même l'accident
mais cette période là je les reprendrai
mon pied alors à force de le tarauder le
pauvre il a décidé d'arrêter l'hiver 54
l'hiver terrible hiver de l'abbé pierre
ou j'ai tellement froid il vous annonce
à tout ce qu'il a décidé d'accepter
l'offre d'un ancien patron du théâtre
des capucines qui s'appelait paul board
qui a été reconvertie dans la limonade
et donc y voit là il devient
représentant bière sur ce type d'un seul
coup dit non à sa carrière et le dernier
soir c'était la bc il est la doublure de
guéthary et et la fin de ses études ou
leurs deux buteurs et de leurs mains
matin ils partaient sur son solex et
sans maquillage
voilà il voyait toujours très bien à
ranger votre père les glières en tout
qu'il était beau sous les lumières il ya
des bougies avec sa canadienne le soir
et puis malheureux quoi bien sûr
malheureux il pleurait parfois ouais il
se confier à vous et vous vous le disiez
écoute papa part il faut que tu partes
il faut que tu te casses d'ici et ils
vous répondez non je peux pas y à toi
oui et moi je lui dis c'est pas une
raison parce qu'on est beaucoup plus
malheureux quand on est enfant et que
les parents ne s'entendent pas moi
j'entendais des engueulades permanente
est pas mieux un j'aurais bon j'aurai
par terre puis j'aurai tellement été
heureux que mon père continue et ça
aurait même changé sûrement ma propre
vie et j'étais assez précoce pour
entendre ça et je me suis battu mais il
restait quand même et ça fait son
malheur et une partie du mien dans cette
période j'ai écrit là-dessus des
chansons un peu un peu il ya le temps de
la rengaine où je raconte cette histoire
qui est une des rares chansons
autobiographiques enfin réellement
autobiographique les autres
autobiographique
je pouvais voir les petites femmes de
pillage et et croiser les doigts
et voilà voilà l'histoire de serge lama
quand votre père prends la décision
d'arrêter vous prenez la décision d'y
arriver c'est peut-être grâce à elle je
suis à regarder la sûreté bien l'assumer
enfin quel prix vous pensez peut-être
pas et des prix à payer qui sont pas
très allants à ce rêve voilà donc après
vous allez vivre toute la famille dans
un petit appartement issy les moulineaux
ça va mieux évidemment il a une vie plus
régulière face à va mieux
cg puis c'est l'arrivée des années les
premiers crédits on peut acheter à
petites voitures et on partait le
dimanche comme tout le monde l'a sur les
routes
allez manger le poulet dans dans l'herbe
avec les fourmis mais je détestais les
pique-niques querelle avec les tables on
s'investit et j'étais contraint de
suivre
alors voilà et quand votre père c'est
sahélienne l'épilogué cette histoire
quand votre père à 60 ans il prend sa
pré retraite
vous faites un album avec lui qui
s'appelle la main père et fils et pour
vos vingt ans de carrière vous lui
offrez la scène du rex
oui c'est beau très très très bon
souvenir bref une tournée aussi une fait
une tournée d'une quarantaine de dates 1
et c'était un moment merveilleux on
dirait qu'on prévoit les choses dans le
sac à dés assez vrai parce que mon père
est mort dans un accident de voiture
neuf mois après oui en soit 184 pendant
napoléon avec ma mère aussi puisqu'ils
ont une même occident et ils sont morts
tous les deux et peut-être sans le
savoir je lui ai offert ça derrière
dernière grande joie mais c'est bien oui
et c'est je ne regrette pas sincèrement
dans mes pistes ya le règlement c'est un
moment j'ai un souvenir de ce rex
c'était on a fait trois jours c'était
merveilleux c'est peut-être le plus beau
souvenir que j'ai de music hall à paris
ouais tu es fantastique dans serge lama
c'est un petit peu marqué par les
accidents il faut bien dire quand même
que tout court non mais c'est vrai au
début de votre carrière
l'accident très grave enrico macias vous
en a parlé d'ailleurs avec son frère est
décédé et dormir dans la voiture jean
claude massias
et puis il y avait aussi dit yann
benedick était votre grand amour
week-end marque et toutes
c'était la pianiste delescluse la
pianiste de l'éclusé qui accompagne tous
les gens qui passent cabaret dont moi de
tous les plus grands des gens sont
passés là bas c'était une femme
merveilleuse et puis cette annonce est
arrêté en plein ciel quoi au moment où
c'était le plus beau restait pour rester
un an et demi couchez vous réapprenez un
marché très difficilement c'est vrai
qu'à 24 ans et c'est difficile de se
remettre d'un marché on ne donnait
aucune chance je pense que c'est mon
métier qui m'a sauvé peu à peu la vie et
reprend ses droits à l'hosto vous
rencontrez daisy voilà donc comme quoi
finalement un scientifique chez philips
voilà et qui est ce que je me suis
raccroché raccrocher à elle pour
survivre voilà lorsque peut-être tiré
par an contre des tiges commencé à avoir
du mal à tenir moralement ouais et alors
c'est marrant enfin marrant c'est
étonnant c'est sur un brancard que vous
enregistrez votre premier succès les
ballons rouges
[Musique]
quand j'étais gosse
dans ces provinces rien ou coup je n'ai
pas long
était crevé je n'ai vendu
mais d'aventurés en aventures de trois
on doit
nouar ans
je n'ai pu fermer ma blessure je t'aime
encore à l'itma
puis 1
e
[Musique]
en voilà
comme quand ma mère
dès le soir
lesquels les 6 1
mon pays
sur le mur il y avait des vies ici sur
le capitalisme
toi tu parles thèse en tablier bleu
quand tu passes sautées en tablier
je m'en vais voir
tout
je ne fais
je suis comme un an
soit comme
je dis que
je n'ai
[Musique]
je t'aime à la folie ce thème
je t'aime à la folie je t'aime
il
nous les avons j'ai mal aux airs
dernière quand est ce qu'on fait mais
quand est ce qu'on fait
l'amour
on se parlait
dalli
on se parlait attendent d'adieu
on se disait un jour
trois mois
et
[Applaudissements]
serge lama bientôt sur scène en mars en
mars
oui on mars à l'olympia fin mars la
dernière semaine de mars et puis une
tournée avant et un petit peu après
qu'est la rentrée prochaine je ferai une
grande tournée au québec
j'irai également plus que certaines
demandes faites moi confiance
m
alors certes la main comme vous êtes
passés pas loin de la mort lors de votre
accident
je vais vous faire une interview
jugement dernier c'est normal
serge lama a dû voler de l'argent dans
le porte monnaie de ta maman quand tu
étais petit jamais il a volé jamais fait
pour piquer de l'argent à ma mère
c'était compliqué vous savez les titres
et provinces et puis je piquais les
sucres serge lama as-tu copié sur ton
voisin en classe pendant les compos oui
as-tu enfermer des élèves du sexe
féminin dans les cabinets non non mais
j'avais déjà vu une sale manie quand
j'étais à la maternelle neuve pas déjà
mais je je piquais des petites filles
avec des épingles
est ce assez large lama est ce que tu te
reprends pour ça oui
ah oui oui serge lama as-tu par donner à
ta mère oui serge lama as tu déjà été
tentée par l'homosexualité
non et j'avais mon meilleur ami qui
était homosexuel et quand comme ça
marche et très mal quand j'étais môme
avec les avec les jeunes filles à jour
j'arrive
et puis je dire j'en ai mais j'en ai
plein monde je vais me taire [__] j'en ai
marre mbia mon pauvre caucourt on peut
pas voir toutes les chansons même temps
serge lama as-tu fait l'amour sans désir
de procréer oui quelle honte tu te
reposes je dirais même que des fois je
les fais volontairement pour ne pas
procréer
serge lama as-tu trompeta femmes
et c'est ta dernière chance serge lama
le jugement dernier cédant 3
et avec ma femme c'est entrer au paradis
serge lama as-tu trompeta maîtresse puis
bapaume connu serge lama 1 tu vraiment
fréquenter les petites femmes de pigalle
et bah non non moi je suis plutôt un
type à bourgeoise oui je suis un peu non
j'aime serge lama tu préfères les femmes
mariées oui comme ça tu les as pas sur
le dos toute la journée
pas forcément mariés mais aussi oui
d'accord
serge lama a tué exiger des femmes des
pratiques contre nature
j'ai pas exigée mais j'ai je leur ai
demandé quoi le gentiment
elles ont dit oui pas tout c'était
c'est bien un cdd
la mort
non je vais vous libérer merci mais
notre sniper bernard henri lévy qui va
arriver
voilà je débriefer il va être très très
drôle je vais passer plein de vannes le
cul de la marouette on vous allez bien
vous rigolez vous n'allez pas perdre au
change
non
quand
j'accueille maintenant bernard henri
lévy
bonsoir bonsoir oui mais le noir rim qui
a quitté new york pour venir nous
rejoindre à paris yvan attal dans le
film ma femme est une actrice et un
carton il faut vraiment agir
moi je m'engage rarement pour les films
et là je m'engage je dis allez le voir
son propre à beaucoup de riz c'est
génial et serge lama donc qui vient
d'avoir droit à une interview du
jugement dernier où on a appris beaucoup
de choses mais je pense que désormais
vous êtes prêts pour le paradis alors de
cuivre auscitain est un gros succès
tout le monde en parle ça se vend très
très bien et pourtant le titre est pas
facile hein vous avez fait des trucs
plus simple il y avait et loge des
intellectuels l'idéologie française
le testament de dieu le siècle de sartre
bon là le titre un peu compliqué malgré
tout les gens l'achètent le titre ses
réflexions sur la guerre le mal et la
fin de l'histoire
précédé de lait damné de la guerre voilà
qu'est ce qu'ils font les gens dans les
librairies demande le nouveau bernard
henri lévy j'imagine ne serait que le
titre est un peu impossible mais c'est
pas c'était le titre que ça t'es sérieux
c'est chercher à faire du marketing
vous savez comment on fait
bien alors le contenu est double au
départ il y avait une série de
reportages pour le journal le monde dans
des pays où existe ce que vous appelez
des guerres oubliées
l'angola le burundi la colombie le sri
lanka le soudan
et ça ça fait à peu près 120 pages de
votre nouveau livre et puis un petit peu
comme sur les ordinateurs vous cliquez
sur des mots circa le texte et
l'hypertexte vous cliquez sur des mots
et vous développez dans une deuxième
partie
certains points de la première partie à
travers des fragments et le style est
très différend entre les deux parties un
style reportage très bien écrit très
très punchy comme ça et puis un style
plus analytique dans les fragments alors
le livre est un succès mais je me
demande si c'est pas finalement pour de
mauvaises raisons
bien sûr c'est agréable d'avoir du
succès surtout que ce livre marque pour
vous d'une certaine façon la fin d'une
excommunication qui avait commencé avec
l'idéologie française
un livre qui traitait du fascisme à la
française et puis avait aussi votre film
le jour et la nuit
la fin de cette excommunication s'est
amorcé avec le siècle de sartre qui vous
a réconcilié avec la gauche est
aujourd'hui ce livre est un succès je
dis peut-être pas pour les bonnes
raisons
dans tous les cas ça y est quoi vous
êtes revenu dans le dans le grand bain
oui le succès c'est toujours des
mauvaises raisons ça la croix je le
crois vraiment je crois qu'un écrivain
il assez nourissier qui dit ça je la
raison un écrivain à quelques milliers
de lecteurs quand on arrive quand un
écrivain avant des dizaines de milliers
ou des centaines de milliers de livres
c'est presque toujours un malentendu
alors là il ya sûrement entendu aussi
dans lequel est ce que justement les
secours n'avait repéré oui je les
repérer c'est à dire que c'est normal
c'est d'actualité comme vous avez été en
il ya une trentaine d'années déjà au
bangladesh à l'époque comme vous avez
bien connu le commandant massoud
tout le monde va parler de massoud
évidemment comment il était qu'est ce
qu'ils faisaient qu'est ce qu'il ferait
s'il était là et c'est bon votre
ambition en fait c'était passé là au
départ même si l'actualité a donné un
relief particulier à votre livre au
départ votre ambition c'était de parler
de ces guerres oubliées ces guerres qui
n'ont pas de sens et guerre insensée
comme vous dites alors que la guerre en
afghanistan a un sens c'était une guerre
en réaction au 11 septembre c'est une
guerre contre le fascisme vert donc
c'est différent c'est vrai que le projet
du livre c'était pas ça c'était d'aller
enquêter d'aller regarder du côté de
ceux dont on ne parle jamais mal parce
que l'afghanistan sais c'est un peu
quand même l'arbre qui cache la forêt
tous les projecteurs du monde sont
aujourd'hui fixés sur l'afghanistan
alléluia il ya d'autres guerres encore
plus angle encore plus terrible que la
guerre va en parler mais avant de passer
au contenu du livre un mélina presse que
vous avez déclarait-il alors maintenant
chaque fois vous approchez d'un garçon
tout le monde se dit qu'elle ait
problème
elle veut devenir esclave sexuelle
donc avant de passer au contenu du livre
on va évacuer aussi des critiques qui
vous ont été faites notamment par arnaud
viviant du style bhl fait du tourisme
guerrier comme houellebecq fait du
tourisme sexuel et c'est vrai que vous
avez une vie bon c'est clair
votre vie est une alternance comme ça
entre des moments très pénibles ce que
vous vivez dans des endroits dont vous
parlez dans votre bouquin et puis aussi
c'est vrai la colombe d'or avec arielle
dombasle boulevard saint germain paris
est-ce que c'est interdit d'être les
deux à la fois du tout non mais évacuons
le nom mais apparemment il ya certain
que ça gêne c'est vrai que pour
l'instant ce qui est important je crois
c'est pas la colombe d'or c'est qu'en
effet j'ai passé l'année dernière à
aller dans ces trous noirs de la planète
c'est-à-dire là où le malheur et est
maximale et dans des endroits dont tout
le monde se moque
soyons clairs et soyons francs des
images du burundi à la télévision il y
en a pas des masses
des images de l'angola y en a pas des
reportages sur les nouvelles y en a pas
donc j'ai essayé de faire ça voilà alors
pour quelles raisons ça c'est une autre
en même temps se servir de son statut de
star pour témoigner pourquoi pas je veux
dire c'est ce que fait goldman quand il
fait des restos du coeur m
il utilise ça mais j'aurais été procédé
l'époux je crois que c'est ce qu'on peut
faire de mieux d'une notoriété nous
rendait ce que la vie vous a donné je
rends oui mais je crois que c'est ce que
doivent faire
comment vous dire je crois que c'est un
devoir quand on a reçu beaucoup c'est la
moindre des choses de rendre un peu et
un intellectuel ça peut servir à ça
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose d'une
explication un peu chrétienne dans cette
idée de se faire pardonner finalement ça
bernard henri jean chrétien c'est un
c'est un vrai scoop là alors on passe au
contenu du livre maintenant donc ces
cinq reportages dans cinq pays ravagé
par des guerres dans personne parce que
vous avez des trous noirs de l'actualité
en tous les cas ça fait pas le 20h ça
c'est clair
nouveau type de guerre parce que c'est
vrai que depuis la chute du communisme
c'est plus des guerres de libération
nationale ou des guerres de résistance à
l'oppression
c'est des guerres sans le sens qui
desanneaux glisser d'une certaine façon
le communisme donner un sens à tous
c'est à dire que c'était une espèce de
grande machine planétaire qui faisait
que n'importe quel guérilla aux îles
moluques ou au fond du fond du sud
soudan était rattaché un combat mondial
les uns étaient du côté des américains
les autres étaient du côté des des
russes etc
et c'est vrai que le communisme en
s'effondrant c'est comme une espèce de
marée qui se seraient retirés et qu'ils
laissent sur la grève des gens qui
continuent de se battre avec une
férocité inouïe moi j'ai vu des choses
et j'ai rapporté des choses dans ce
livre qui que je n'arrive pas à oublier
enfin qu'ils sont qui sont au-delà en
tout cas de l'imagination et ça n'a plus
de sens vous dira interrogé aujourd'hui
un angolais un an gaulle et 10 à 20 ans
il avait l'impression moi je rends
compte par exemple apporter un bol qui
est une petite ville du sud de l'angola
je rencontre un vieux portugais qui
était un des premiers progressiste e
rallye au mp relais qui me dit il ya 20
ans j'avais l'impression de me battre
pour le communisme l'international
maguer avait un sens
aujourd'hui je ne sais plus pourquoi je
me bats je suis comme un canard sans
tête qui continueraient de courir
n'importe des tisons lâcher la corde
qu'il est relié à l'universel voilà et
c'est vrai que jusqu'ici les galettes et
la continuation de la politique par
d'autres moyens
aujourd'hui c'est la continuation de
rien du tout ils se battent soit la
continuation du tout soi d'un certain
qu'à la continuation de la religion par
le coma
mais ce n'est plus la continuation ces
guerres dont je parle ça n'est plus là
quand il avait dit à l'horreur de mourir
s'ajoute celle de mourir pour rien non
seulement y meurt mais ils savent pas
pourquoi ils n'ont aucune espèce d'idée
des raisons pour lesquelles il pourrait
mourir est plus grave que ça comment
arrêter une guerre qui n'a pas de sens
c'est à dire pas de raison de l'arrêté
s'allumant ils savent pas pourquoi ils
se battent c'est une espèce d'animalité
postes historiques qui rejoint un peu
les combats préhistorique d'une certaine
façon en tire des tribus qui se battent
sans vraiment savoir pourquoi on rejoint
la préhistoire alors en temps c'est plus
compliqué que ça passe que par exemple
dans le cas du soudan je suis allé au
sud soudan où j'avais le sentiment en un
premier temps qu'en effet c'était une
guerre absurde une guerre tribale
et puis regardons de plus près et même
d'ailleurs sur le moment puisque le
hasard a fait que j'ai survolé un champ
pétrolifère en activer enfin en
préparation autour duquel l'armée
soudanaise avait nettoyé les villages au
sud soudan c'est ça vous avez les
compagnies pétrolières qui s'installe et
20 km 30 km 100 km autour on brûle les
maisons on chasse les gens on liquide ce
qui n'obtempère pas et vous voyez des
petites colonnes de pauvres gens avec un
maigre balle l'eau sur la tête tout ce
qu'ils ont pu emporter de leur vie
d'avant qui skie qui partent plus loin
alors là par exemple il ya un sens là
c'est clairement le régime islamiste de
khartoum
appuyez sur les grandes compagnies
pétrolières canadiennes malaise
peut-être demain française il ya
aujourd'hui un projet pétrolier dans une
région du sud soudan total fina elf
vieille connaissance tout de même
et là c'est cette alliance diabolique un
cette alliance terrible entre le pouvoir
islamiste et les pétroliers qui fait que
les gens sont jetés sur les routes est
traité comme du bétail
ouais donc là on revient dans une
logique qui n'est pas une logique
insensée
donc c'est très compliqué vous savez
c'est un livre il n'ya pas de ya pas de
régaler pas dire pas de réponse est rien
de certitudes sur la queue du doigt lors
c'est bien servir beaucoup enfin il n'y
a pas que dire que j'aime beaucoup
oui c'est vrai en un sens oui c'est oui
bien sûr parce que ça me change un peu
c'est vrai qu'il m'est arrivé c'est vrai
d'être plus sûre de moi vrai vous en
serez sûr de ce que vous dites des
foires peux pas rentrer je suis rentré
je suis rentré ce livre là c'est en
effet laventure la plus la plus terrible
de ma vraie
la première aventure politique dont je
ne sois pas redevenu intacte inde m
et c'est vrai que j'en reviens avec
autant de certitude après les vives et
voir ce que vous racontez pas de ville
fantôme peuplé de spectre des épaves des
ville jonchées de cadavres
mais comme vous dites ainsi nommé et un
compte et c'est à dire que là on
n'enterre pas les gens dont se
repaissent des chiens trop gros là vous
voyez l'enfer quoi c'est à dire que vous
découvrez cette lèpre qui est en train
de ronger le monde un petit peu une
lèpre lente langues
mais un peu comme ceux qui ont sont
revenus des camps de concentration c'est
à dire qu'ils ont vu l'horrible convenu
l'indicible et je pense vous avez ce
qu'il fallait pas voir les choses sont
pas ceux qui ne sont jamais comparable
et et notamment dans ce cas là mais
c'est vrai que le spectacle par exemple
un exemple précis parce qu'en effet les
villes fantômes tout ça ça peut paraître
très abstrait ou à ceux qui nous
écoutent mais par exemple un jour dans
un village des monts nuba je suis tombé
sur une petite case mate de rondins et
de paille où il y avait trois hommes et
un petit enfant en train de mourir de
faim en train d'achever de mourir de
faim il n'était pas blessé il n'avait
pas reçu une balle il était juste
exemple il était il y avait un des
hommes qui portaient un petit garçon
contre lui qui lui murmurait de temps en
temps une phrase que l'enfant
n'entendait pas il y en avait un autre
dont on avait l'impression qu'il était
mort déjà par endroits et qui avait que
je ne sais pas assez je me souviens de
ces mains qui continuait de de remuer
kessé une gratte et la chemise de se
tendre on avait l'impression que les les
mains étaient comme des organes
étrangers qui vivaient encore alors que
le reste est des morts le troisième
l'oeil et et vitreux
il était apparemment vivant est déjà
mort ce spectacle là un l'image de trois
hommes et d'un enfant en train de
s'éteindre de faim dans l'impuissance
absolue de celui qui était là c'est à
dire moi j'étais à des heures de 2,2 à
des jours de marché à des heures de tout
autre moyen de locomotion de toute base
connue
j'avais un vague talkie walkie que tu
démontres adducteurs ont essayé par tous
les moyens
évidemment personne ne venait cette
image là d'abord elle et elle est
inoubliable et ces situations là c'est
les situations de ces guerres oubliées
contemporain alors
ça donne le vertige votre bouquin parce
qu'à un moment on se dit et si la fin du
monde si la fin des temps c'était cette
abomination on n'a jamais pensé à ça
nous on a une vision progressiste des
choses on pense que peu ou prou c'est
quand même de mieux en mieux et on se
dit en lisant le bouquin sur tout et si
ça se terminer comme ça j'en surtout
nous en effet que nous appartenons à une
génération qui a cru moi quand j'avais
20 ans je pensais qu'il y aurait une fin
de l'histoire mais je pensais qu'elle
serait que ce serait une apocalypse
joyeuse royer en gros que ce serait la
révolution
ouais et c'est vrai que la danse est
dans ces situations-là en colombie par
exemple qui est un pays en proie à des à
la guerre des mafias où vous avez aidé
où on fait la chasse aux clochards dans
les égouts de la ville où on fait la
chasse aux mômes
il ya des contrats qui sont mis sur la
tête des mômes d'un quartier on prend 20
gosses parce qu'ils mangent des rares
parce qu'ils font baisser l'immobilier
du quartier en gros sa gelée je le
raconte dans le livre
un groupe d'enfants dont le principal
tort est de faire baisser les prix de
l'immobilier du quartier il ya un ancien
flic qui rassemble les voisins qui crée
une junte de nettoyage social ou la
route adélie mme pieza sociale qui met
un contrat sur la tête des vins môme et
puis on les courses et on l'est on les
flingues l'un après l'autre
donc c'est vrai que là on a l'impression
d'un ordre social qui se délite d'une
société qui sait dès qu'ils se
détruisent l'intérieur d'une histoire
qui s'achève sauf que au lieu d'être cet
acharnement joyeux que nous imaginions
et qu'imaginaient les philosophes c'est
une
c'est un achèvement sinistre c'est un
achèvement désastreux désastreux c'est
plus l'astre de la révolution l'indian
c'est le le désastre de l'inhumanité
vous dormez comment la nuit depuis que
vous êtes revenu
ça dépend des jours ça dépend des jours
comme je suis en effet comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure je suis un un
tempérament heureux je suis assez fort
pour être double bien sûr donc je
m'arrive de dormir pas trop mal mais il
m'arrive alors s'ils ont foulé le fond'
il m'arrive en effet d'être d'avoir
c'est tout ça qui me revient c'est vrai
et d'avoir le sentiment en plus cons je
crois souvent les les correspondants de
guerre où les gens qui assistent à des
choses de ce genre
il m'arrive d'avoir pas le regret est
presque là presque la honte
de de n'avoir fait que passer quand ce
type là dont vous parliez parle de
tourisme guerrier bien sûr qu'il a
raison évidemment qu'on fait toujours du
tourisme guerrier quand on va passer
quinze jours trois semaines un mois
mon autre fois j'ai passé six mois au
bangladesh en effet ça n'est que six
mois on s'en va les autres restent et le
grand partage de l'humanité vous savez
c'est ça c'est ceux qui restent et ceux
qui ne font que passer ça c'est
incontestable alors c'est vrai que la
nuit à ce que le billet de retour ce
sont bien de retour
voilà alors ça c'est l'inégalité c'est
plus un c'est plus important que
l'inégalité entre les riches et les
pauvres c'est plus important que
l'inégalité entre les entre les jolies
et les moins joli c'est plus important
que tout ça l'inégalité de en gros
d'être né dans un lieu de damnation et
date revenez dans un lieu de nantis
voilà et ce livre c'est en effet le
petit effort modeste d'un antique qui a
essayé d'aller y voir de l'autre côté du
miroir
comment ça se passe de l'autre côté de
l'apartheid planétaire parce que c'est
ça qui se passe mais aujourd'hui les
pays occidentaux ils ont fait un appart
heinze est pas l'apartheid d'afrique du
sud 1
c'est un apartheid mondial avec d'un
côté les pays riches pas seulement
l'europe et pas seulement en occident il
ya des pays arabes qui sont très riches
par exemple et puis de l'autre côté
c'est ces trous noirs c'est rooney c'est
no man's land
ces zones grises un trou noir en
astronomie vous savez c'est à c'est une
densité très grande trêve de plus en
plus grande à mesure que le lieu se
résorbe et là c'est un peu ça le burundi
c'est un lieu qui se résorbent sur la
carte de nos imaginaires il existe de
moins en moins ils occupent de moins en
moins de place et puis tout se passe
comme si la la densité de malheurs et de
souffrance s'accroissait en conséquence
alors lui réflexion sur la guerre
et la famille
voir
les de l'année
chez grasset
[Musique]
merci ont trouvé quatre ce témoignage
c'est ce qu'on va faire maintenant un
anti portrait chinois dans la bouche
[Applaudissements]
ont-ils portrait chinois ça veut dire il
ya le portrait chinois si vous étiez une
fleur je serai à myosotis lentilles
portrait chinois par exemple c'est si
vous étiez un défaut si j'étais un
défaut ouais si j'adore si j'étais un
défaut mais quel défaut vous seriez
l'esprit de sérieux je crois je crains
je crains c'est bien si vous étiez une
injure
le silence si vous étiez une maladie la
lucidité un accident la chance une
perversion
le goût du secret si vous étiez un vice
si j'étais un vice la cybèle fera le si
beau titre de larbaud ce vice impuni la
lecture il était un vide je serai la
lecture une trahison
je serai comme ces gens qui militent ou
qui se bat contre leur tribu contre leur
camp par exemple je ne sais pas les
aristocrates ou les prêtres français en
89 qui rejoignait le tiers état c'est
une des plus belles attitudes me
semble-t-il ceux qui choisissent de
penser contre eux mêmes ou contrôler
leur penser contre soi même penser
contre soi mais oui ou contre les siens
les pieds noirs qui devenait porto qui
prenait le parti du fln pendant la
guerre d'algérie
ça ça me semble une attitude très noble
ceci est une arme
si j'étais une arme un stylo c'est le
seul dont je suis capable de me servir
cette différence entre vous et nabab il
a répondu un cutter et semaine dernière
ce sera sûrement d'autres est différent
c'est une interview que ça permet de
vous étiez un supplice la volupté une
cicatrice le souvenir notamment des
volutes et si vous étiez un poison la
vérité dont seul génie s'il disait
qu'elle était le poison des dictatures
que lesdits nature se corroder par le
travail de la vérité se situe une panne
je crois que j'essaierai de dérégler
d'envoyer un virus dans les derniers
ordinateurs de ben laden soit avec
lequel il est sans doute en train de
préparer ses prochains attentats ray un
dictateur si j'étais un dictateur
j'oblige ray et thierry ardisson a
diffusé chaque samedi 10 minutes en
boucle l'image de l'angola et du burundi
qui peut l'être
si vous êtes une infirmité
si j'étais une infirmité la surdité
réussir et non la patience l'impatience
moi c'est probablement mon mon pire
défaut enfin voilà la patience un
assassin si j'étais un assassin jeu
j'essaierai d'assassiner pam avoisinera
surgit la mauvaise part de moi-même que
je connais bien et ça en général c'est
un crime parfait mais celui là si vous
étiez à microbes
j'essaierai d'être un d'être un microbe
sympathique des train d'être un microbe
de gauche qui irait chercher de
préférence les [__] et parfois les
combes et surtout les salles aux
microbes sélectif une torture
je ne sais pas si je voulais torturer
quelqu'un je crois que ce serait la
différence
voilà une humiliation je me suiciderai
parce que je si j'étais une imitation je
mens je crois que je ne supporterai ni
d'être humilié ni encore moins des
supporter l'humiliation des autres donc
je disparaîtrai dans votre nuage de
fumée jugement dernier serge lama
j'accompagnerai sera encore gatwech de
temps
si vous étiez un terroriste je serai le
colonel fabien
c'est à dire je serai un bon terrorisme
la définition d'un bon terroristes c'est
quelqu'un qui défend une juste cause et
qui n'a pas d'autre moyen que la
violence de la défendre donc posé des
bombes dans paris en 42 colonel fabien
ça je crois que c'est du bon terrorisme
et ça n'a évidemment rien à voir avec
cette caricature elle que sont les
terroristes d'aujourd'hui mais c'est
comme faire la guerre sans l'aimer quoi
c'est comme faire la guerre sur les mecs
qui était un mode malraux et qui est
elle a deux filles la devise du
commandant massoud ray si vous étiez une
bourre
moi je serais très chaud serait la
petite mort histoire
d'amis de la guerre
et chez grasset
j'accueille maintenant jean charles
brisard et guillaume dasquié
bonsoir moi moi ça alors jean charles
brisard vous étiez responsable du
renseignement économique chez vivant dit
puis vous avez fait une enquête sur al
qaïda la base l'organisation de ben
laden et à la demande des services
français est votre rapport a été
apportées comme une belle pomme sur le
bureau de la maîtresse par jacques
chirac en était allé voir george w bush
guillaume dasquié vous êtes rédacteur en
chef d'une lettre d'information
spécialisée dans le renseignement c'est
ce qui s'appelle intelligence online
voilà alors vous connaissez depuis
longtemps tous les deux vous avez décidé
de mettre vos informations en commun
pour publié chez denoël ben laden la
vérité interdite vous savez comment
furent normal qu'on vous fasse une
interview vérité
le problème c'est que je suis pas plus
sévère avec le public de cette émission
qu'avec mes enfants et on voit bien on
voit bien que les tiens pas du tout quoi
bon alors votre bouquin très intéressant
fait beaucoup de bruit vous montrer que
oussama ben laden n'est que
officiellement en rupture avec l'arabie
saoudite
êtes-vous dit en parlant de ben laden
qu'il en incarne plus la face cachée
serait ça fait à peu près de 30 ans que
l'arabie saoudite cache son jeu et je
dirais qu'on ferme les yeux en même
temps sur sur cette face cachée de
l'arabie saoudite qui qui sponsorise qui
financent par son establishment je
dirais financier bancaire le
fondamentalisme et en particulier ben
laden de plessisville des années 80
ouais alors si vous fait marrer vous
c'est l'histoire des demi frères
quand on dit ben laden il a des frères
dans un pays où il ya la polygamie et
guillaume dans un pays où il ya la
polygamie ne peut pas y avoir deux
demi-frères oui c'est vrai en arabie
saoudite
quand un homme comme sheikh mohammed bin
laden le père d'osama bin plusieurs à
cinq ans deux enfants avec plusieurs
femmes c'est une tribu c'est un clan et
naturellement on n'est pas demi frère en
est membre du même clan c'est pareil il
faut comprendre avec la psychologie
l'assignation de là-bas pour vous-même
laden ceni un fou ni un traître
par rapport à la décennie non on dit on
dit d'ailleurs c'est le produit de son
pays alors produit à la fois religieux
bien sûr le fondamentalisme et puis le
produit financier ben laden c'est un
homme d'affaires un homme d'affaires qui
a bien réussi qui négociait au début des
années 80 qui a été désigné par le
patron des services de renseignement
saoudiens comme représentant de l'arabie
saoudite et en afghanistan pour aller
sur le front pour recruter des
combattants
et puis qui plus tard a pu à partir de
là gagner de l'arabie saoudite faire ses
affaires toujours mais à ce moment là
dedans un dessin terroristes bien sûr
alors votre livre c'est la première
tentative d'explication disons cohérente
de ce qui s'est passé parce que jusque
là on a vu des choses n'a pas très bien
compris ce qui se passait pour vous tout
s'explique par le contrôle des matières
premières à commencer bien entendu par
le pétrole
aujourd'hui en dehors du golfe persique
les principales réserves sont en asie
centrale
et oui c'est vrai que le kazakhstan a
été surnommé assez tôt et parler les
compagnies pétrolières américaines
then you koweit le nouveau koweit sa fin
sans guidon alors j'explique à nos amis
téléspectateurs donc il ya évidemment le
golfe persique qui produit du pétrole il
ya un deuxième endroit où il ya beaucoup
de pétrole
c'est l'asie centrale pour acheminer ce
pétrole d'asie centrale sur la mer pour
devenir le prendre avec des tankers
effectivement il faut faire un pipe line
d'un pipeline gazoduc à un oléoduc
voilà inverse les organistes ans d'où
l'importance de l'afghanistan ont
compris pourquoi ce pays contrairement
aux pays dont vous parliez bernard henri
lévy dont on parle pas celui-là
intéresse les gens parce que c'est celui
par route doit transiter le pétrole qui
vient d'asie centrale
et alors l'arabie saoudite et les usa il
ya une espèce de concurrence comme ça
pour contrôler l'afghanistan
si vous voulez le pétrole nous aveugle
en afghanistan est effectivement
l'occident a besoin d'un régime fort
régime taliban qui est en petit en place
elle s'en accommode
et effectivement elle ferme les yeux sur
la tyrannie de ce régime et puis elle
nous aveugle également en arabie
saoudite puis ce qu'on ferme les yeux
sur le soutien qu'apporte
l'establishment l'arabie saoudite aux
terroristes c'est très clair alors donc
les américains quand bush a été élu avec
le soutien du lobby pétrolier alors que
vous vous expliquer tout ça a dit
chesnais kendira et seppi d'autres
viennent des sociétés pétrolières des
gens qui travaillaient dans le pétrole
et on sait bien que bush était élu à
l'aide de ce lobby pétrolier public oui
alors ils ont table des négociations dès
qu'ils arrivent contrairement à clint à
s'engraisser arrêté il au terme des
négociations avec les talibans
oui disent vous nous livrez ben laden
vous participez les talibans vous nous
livrez ben laden vous participez à un
gouvernement élargi
qu'on discute au cours d'une loya jirga
avec toutes les l'assemblée du peuple
afghan et puis au dessus de 100 mais le
roi zahir shah voilà donc les américains
sont en train depuis un an vous ai donc
fait du pognon quoi les américains ont
commencé par négocier avec les talibans
c'est la seule chose qu'il voulait c'est
ben laden qui avait commis des attentats
contre le bateau au sss collègues
ferrand ont dit aux talibans
rendez-nous une partie de votre pouvoir
on va y mettre les recherches avec qui
on discute depuis le 16 mai 2001 et s'il
vous plaît donnez nous aussi osama bin
laden qui est ce chef qui est tellement
proches de mollah omar et finalement
c'est terrible parce que on négocie avec
déformante fondamentalistes ont négocié
comment on négocierait avec finalement
un pays riche en leur promettant de l'or
contre les concessions la billettique
eux ils s'en fichent d'être à l'onu ce
qu'ils veulent c'est imposé l'émirat
islamique d'afghanistan et donc ont
négocié avec le diable et peut-être
perte ou alors les américains négocient
en avant le 11 septembre 2001 avec donc
les talibans en leur disant c'est soit
un tapis d'or soit un tapis de bombes
c'est à dire en soi soit on vous couvre
d'or on vous laisse au gouvernement on
trouve une solution et on fait passer
notre pays klein qui vient d'asie
centrale
soit vous bombarde voilà c'est la fraude
c'est une phrase qui était prononcée par
tom simons a donc été le représentant de
la diplomatie américaine dans les
dernières négociations et ça ne manque
pas de piquant parce que après demain
lundi se déroulera à berlin
la première réunion de négociation qui
sur l'afghanistan
et c'est précisément à berlin le 17
juillet qu'elles ont achoppé et que tom
simons a dit ce sera un tapis d'or ou un
tapis de bombes voilà alors évidemment
ces négociations qui sont entamées par
les américains avec les talibans font
que le gouvernement américain relâche un
peu la pression sur la lutte
antiterroriste et c'est rassurant d'une
certaine façon parce que quand il ya eu
l'histoire des world trade center tout
le monde s'est dit bon ils sont pas très
forts les services secrets américains et
quand on lit votre bouquin on apprend
qu'en fait ils ont un peu relâché la
pression et vous parlez d'un type qui
s'appelle john o'neill du fbi qui a
démissionné parce qu'ici il a dit au
gouvernement américain
vous vous occupez pas assez de la lutte
antiterroriste moi je démissionne le
drame de la faire c'est que ce john
o'neill est devenu responsable de la
sécurité pour le world trade center et
qu'il est mort
ironie de l'histoire ironie du sort il
est mort le 11 septembre 2001 dans l'est
dans les ruines dans les cendres du wall
trade salvat c'est la conséquence
logique intérêt cet aveuglement être à
l'étranger
kid rock qui devient qui se retourne
contre nous qui deviennent un
aveuglement un terme finalement la
diplomatie américaine se dit on peut pas
à la fois s'accommoder de ces régimes et
discuter avec eux et puis effectivement
laissé faire des enquêteurs du fbi à y
aller dans ces différents pays pour
mettre en cause précisément ses réseaux
et ses pays et c'est pour ça qu'ils
effectivement malheureusement le
gouvernement américains freine les
enquêtes du fbi à y voilà et celle de
john o'neill ces négociations
n'aboutissent pas un les négociations
entre les américains et talibans qui
aurait donc régler le problème du
'pipeline' n'aboutissent pas et ben
laden c'est que comme c'est pas le tapis
dorsale est le tapis de bombes
donc il dit je vais frapper le premier
on le dit
team américain en négociation le dit
clairement aux talibans ouais ben laden
frappe le premier le 11 septembre nous
des aliments sont acculés effectivement
là tout s'enchaîne et c'est bien parce
que les américains donc la négociation
des américains avec les talibans najat
oui ben laden fait son attentat du du 11
septembre
et maintenant les américains ont de
bonnes raisons évidemment d'aller
bombarder l'afghanistan tout en ouvre
les yeux voilà attendant messieurs sont
leurs rangs le contrôle et on peut
imaginer qu'à l'issue de ce qui se passe
actuellement s'il arrive à contrôler peu
ou prou le régime afghan
ils pourront construire ce fana le
'pipeline' keira d'asie centrale jusqu'à
la mer et donc à l'échelle de la
cheminée en occident donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'on s'est tous fait
avoir par la propagande américaine
non non ça c'est ça c'est une une
opinion intime et personnelle des
produits agricoles aux états unis le 11
septembre le 12 on nous a dit voilà
c'est terrible tout le monde avait l'air
très étonné tout ça quand on lit votre
bouquin et qu'on lui fait confiance en
tous les cas on se dit que finalement
voilà tout ça était pas si son fusil
sadibou vous chérissez surpris que ça je
veux dire non bien sûr
non c'est ce qui est terrifiant mais
quand on dit que c'est pas uniquement il
s'agit pas d'accuser les américains
d'abord c'est pas tous les américains
c'est des intérêts américains qui ont pu
jouer un rôle qui a eu des conséquences
gravissimes
mais tous les autres pays étaient
d'accord enfin n'oubliez pas que on
décrit également la réaction du ministre
français des affaires étrangères hubert
védrine 1 17 juillet 2001 qui dit et
donc à l'issue de cette fameuse réunion
de berlin qui dit bon ben c'est vrai que
ça se passe pas ces négociations se
déroulent mal revenons voir le roi
afghans et donc et c'est vrai que quand
le 17 juillet on voit ce communiqué en
ligne
de quel droit nous parle-t-on et
effectivement c'est après qu'on comprend
que donc les français et également aux
prises mais il les français comme les
britanniques comme d'autres suivez ces
négociations c'étaient les petits qui
suivait mais c'est le bloc
industrialisés qui avance avec ses
intérêts
le principal financier de ben laden on
le sait aujourd'hui c'est le numéro
c'est le premier banquier saoudien
mahfouz il se trouve que kate de
naplouse est connue des américains
depuis longtemps et surtout du clan bush
pourquoi parce qu'il a permis à la
famille bush au père et au fils de
monter leur affaire pétrolière au texas
il les a financés à la fin des années 70
et au milieu des années 80 alors que
précisément le père était président des
états unis
c'est éric voilà donc on est on est au
milieu de ce double jeu de ce double
langage mais qui est gering conséquence
logique de cette histoire on a voulu on
est aveuglé pendant tant d'années
face à tous ces problèmes là
dans le raisonnement qui viennent nous
est retenue laisse supposer que ben
laden aurait préparé son attentat il ya
trois semaines avant le 11 septembre
or nous savons nous savons qu'un
attentat comme celui là il ya eu
d'autres investigations que les vôtres
qui ont été faites et qui indique qu'il
a fallu des mois peut être des années
pour former les kamikazes pour former
les formes et technologiquement les
formes et moralement mentalement c'est
un travail de très longue haleine
donc moi je pense en effet que la
diplomatie américaine soit immoral
qu'elle ait commis des erreurs les
occidentaux moi je suis le premier à le
dire moi j'étais le premier à protester
lorsque au mois d'avril ou de mai
dernier chirac et jospin par exemple de
manière à mon avis déshonorante ont
refusé de recevoir le commandant massoud
et ils ont refusé de recevoir le
commandant massoud probablement parce
qu'ils avaient des bonnes raisons de
politique peut-être du genre de celles
dont vous parlez de le faire néanmoins
je dis que ça suffit pas parce qu'il
faut pas non plus faire l'impasse par
exemple sur la dimension fanatiques
religieuses hors de toute rationalité
économique et politique d'aidé
de ben laden je crois que quel que soit
le lobby pétrolier quelle que soit
l'attitude de bush ben laden est
quelqu'un qui de toute façon est animé
par une espèce de haine ni liste de
l'occident jean-charles on n'a pas voulu
s'écarter précisément du chemin consiste
à faire une thèse ou formuler des
hypothèses sur cette situation qui est
très complexe précisé mme on a voulu se
documenter le plus possible avant de
parler avant d'écrire et c'est ce qu'on
a fait ce qu'on a fait et quand l'ours
qu'effectivement une enquête sur ces
réseaux et qu'on voit bien
qu'effectivement il ya un mouvement si
vous les circulaires et que on retrouve
on retrouve au centre de ce ca
sélectivement l'arabie saoudite les
intérêts pétroliers des grands princes
saoudiens qui sont au coeur du
financement de ben laden quand même fait
une cohérence à tous à ya une cohérence
à tout cela leur explication c'est par
le pétrole de l'asie centrale qui est
quelque chose dont on nous parle pas
tous les jours l économie cet épisode
quoi qu'il en veut pour preuve une
déclaration conjointe de la russie et
d'iran il ya quelques jours en pleine
guerre lorsque alors que les canons
tonnent encore demandant la convocation
d'un sommet pétrolier dans la caspienne
à 100 rihanna où on se partageraient
évidemment le gâteau et les russes
comment les russes là dedans il
s'apprête à matraquer des tchétchènes
pour l'instant qu'est ce que font les
russes réponse il s'apprête à matraquer
les tchétchènes intervenu alors là avec
deux lances avec un blanc seing absolue
ça ça faisait partie du deal
je soutiens on vous soutient sur ben
laden et vous nous cassez pas les
bonbons sur le terrain les alors pour
être plus précis les russes
ces derniers jours surtout financer le
carburant des tadjik pour qu'ils
arrivent plus tôt dans kaboul et donc
pour inverser les plans faut en tout cas
pour chambouler les plans de
l'administration
troisièmement enfin américaine et de
l'onu sur la façon dont on allait gérer
l'après talibans
elle avait été interdite par an sans
visa guillaume dasquié sécher
mais m
ouais
et maintenant président du boeny
et plus
[Musique]
tiens pendant deux semaines
rich ans
à
béchard
les gens vivent
une légende vivante est parmi nous ce
soir
tiens
chasse et légendes vivantes est parmi
nous ce soir
richard 100 millions d'albums vendus
dans le monde
vêtu en 60 ans de carrière riche en son
concert le 26 à paris le 27 danemark et
le 28 à bruxelles
wright charrs 71 ans et 200 concerts par
an
[Applaudissements]
red chasse bonsoir halo reach a rejeté
en 1930 en géorgie est ce qui explique
sans doute la chanson georgia on my mind
dans une famille très pauvre père absent
parce qu'il travaillait sur le réseau
ferroviaire et votre mère vous élève
avec la première femme de son mari
comment est ce possible c'est très rare
ça quand même que deux femmes qui ont
été mariées avec le même homme accepte
d'élever un enfant ensemble
ah oui c'est étrange mais j'ai du mal à
le comprendre
j'étais gosse et bien sûr j'ai eu de la
chance
bien sûr ma mère était toujours là plus
personne n'a plus sa carte ans c'était
la chaîne faire mais l'autre dame elle
m'aimait parce que elle n'avait pas
d'enfant donc je suis devenu numéro 1
sur sa vie donc c'était très agréable
pour moi je sois yade m parce que notre
dame
lorsque j'avais des ennuis et l'empêcher
ma mère de me frappe c'est
extraordinaire c'est qu'il y en a une
que richard s'appelait mama et l'autre
il l'appelait matin voilà comment ça se
passait alors là il dès l'âge de 3 ans
un voisin vous apprend à jouer du piano
des mélodies avec un seul doigt et c'est
comme ça que vous découvrez la musique
c'est tout à fait ça sapere aude
c'était un homme merveilleux parce que
ils devaient savoir qu'il y avait
quelque chose à l'intérieur de moi il
aurait pu facilement dit elle au niveau
de moi petit gamin tu vas pas que je
suis en train de m'entraîner mais il a
dit non cet enfant eh bien il a tout
arrêté pour entendre cette musique et
c'est comme cela que il a commencé à
m'apprendre à jouer avec as de ce doigt
alors à l'âge de 5 ans vous vivez
richard le premier dame de votre vie
votre frère se noie devant vos yeux dans
un baquet plein d'eau pendant que votre
mère repasse
et comme les vêtements de votre frère
sont gorgés d'eau vous êtes incapable de
le ressortir du baquet est ce que c'est
ce traumatisme qui a commencé à vous
faire perdre la vue je pense pas que ce
soit en perdre mon frère c'était une
chose peut être ma vie c'était tout à
fait différent c'était pas liés je pense
que le glaucome était responsable de la
pax prime à vue l'amendement des frères
et bien j'en ai souffert pendant de
nombreuses années parce que je sais
sentir ce passage j'avais l'impression
que je refuse pouvoir le sauver donc il
a fallu longtemps pour que je puisse
récupérer mais
le glaucome et bien c'était responsable
de ma cécité alors sait-on vous avez
définitivement perdu la vue et votre
mère vous y avez préparé parce que ça a
pris un certain nombre de mois et votre
mère vous j'avais préparé et elles vous
disent hey tu es aveugle
tu n'es pas idiot et elle comprend très
bien votre mère que votre salut passe
par votre autonomie et elle vous apprend
pendant toute cette période de perte de
vue elle vous apprend les gestes
courants à pour un aveugle
exact mais tout à fait à ma mère je sais
pas comment elle était si intelligente
si mali une si grande perception mais
vous savez tout à fait qu'il soit ma
mère elle m'a pris elle m'a préparé pour
cette fille quand je viendrai à vers la
haye la met l'accent sur le fait que
écoute il faut apprendre comment
survivre tout seul et matoush outils
qu'il ya tout jeu de façon de faire tout
il faut trouver simplement la bonne
façon pour toi alors là vous êtes placé
dans un établissement pour aveugles et
s'ouvre cette pensionnaire
et si j'ai une école c'est étrange parce
que on sépare dans cette école les
sourds et les aveugles les garçons et
les filles et les blancs et les noirs
alors que tout le monde est aveugle donc
ya pas de raison de séparer les blancs
et les noirs lieu croyais vieux il
savait tout à fait à vue c'est tout à
fait vrai
je me suis posé cette question pendant
toute ma vie et je ne comprends toujours
à cette époque là c'était comme ça
c'était comme ça alors jusqu'à l'âge de
15 ans dans cette école vous étudiez le
braille vous apprenez à écrire le
braille à lire le braille
vous apprenez la musique vous est
influencé par des gens comme art tatum
artichauts mais aussi des gens comme
chopin sibelius mozart alors c'est
l'époque où vous composez vos premiers
morceaux vous créer un orchestre qui
s'appelle de shop boys vous êtes dingues
de musique à cette époque mais autre
drame dans votre vie en 1945 vous avez
15 ans et là votre mère meurt vous êtes
incapable de manger vous êtes incapable
de dormir et vous est même incapable de
pleurer et vous allez voir une vieille
femme qui s'appelle mabec et cette
vieille femme on disait si le paradis
existe elle doit vraiment y aller parce
qu'elles le méritent et mabec vous aide
à ne plus vous sentir coupable de la
mort de votre frère et de la mort de
votre maire de chanteloup ces six
flèches mais ceux-ci fraîcheur d'âme
mabec comme vous dites
eh bien oui tout arranger dans ma vie en
fait c'est qu'elle a fait c'est quand
elle m'a fait pleurer c'était la
première fois je n'ai pas pu pleurer
après la mort de ma mère m'aime avait
fait pleurer parce qu'elle m'a dit une
chose tout s'agissait d'une loi de say
never 8
c'est comme ça que nous sommes bel et
bien est ce que tu penses que c'est ce
qu'elle veut que tu fasses est ce que
c'est pour ça que le cas helvétique
il faut toujours continuer mais ce
départ laisse pas ce que tu as toujours
dit que ma mère yes
alors là vous sortez de la dépression et
à 15 ans vous quittez cette institution
vous commencez à jouer dans des clubs et
c'est une période difficile pour vous
vous mangez souvent des des sardines des
haricots secs du pain période
extrêmement difficile pour vous et en
1947 à l'âge de 17 ans vous vous
installer à seattle et là vous
rencontrez quincy jones et deux ans plus
tard en 1949
vous faites votre premier disque exacte
tout à fait tout ça c'est vrai
travailler dans un club à seattle qui
s'appelle est là où il y avait des jeux
d'argent à l'étagé des antiquités à eau
et pic attendu et n'a commencé à écouter
mon trio et il est venu me voir m'a dit
écoute commun est ce que tu aimerais
faire un disque et bien sûr oui j'étais
excité ah ouais je vais pouvoir faire
mon premier disque je ne connaissais
rien à l'aspect argent je m'en foutais
je voulais simplement faire un disque et
en 49 c'est là où j'ai fait ma première
disque qui s'appellait ses fashion plm
voilà et ce n'est qu'à l'âge de 24 ans
en 1954 l'année ou pour vous c'est si
terrible charge lama l'année du l'hiver
froid de 54 quand votre père arrête de
chanter que vous enregistrez hagen woman
alors il ya ce soir sur le plateau avec
nourrichard un garçon qui était un
réalisateur qui vient de faire son
premier film qui a beaucoup de succès
qui s'appelle yvan attal et yvan attal a
voulu intitulé son premier court métrage
i got you man et il est là ce soir ils
vous regardez vous admire beaucoup
mais aussi
j'entre
[Musique]
georges lot
/
j'ai dix ans je mange
débutée
j'y vais
m
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
kim il ment
le vert
non
si victor et givenchy
ona schéma
g
m
mais
c
lobo
m
je suis
non
washington
oh
tous les records
alors
chaque année
je
m
ja
pas d'accord
enfin
bonjour
chefo
chut
je veux pas
le chouchou
cheney
le second smartphone
oh
ouais
[Applaudissements]
c
chandler
merci m en concert le 26 à paris le 27
et le 28 à bruxelles et je remercie jean
pierre gross qui nous a aidés ce soir
pour que richardson avec nous merci
beaucoup c'est un vrai bonheur vous avez
vous avez eue pendant votre carrière à
faire face à elvis presley et ensuite
aux beatles ça pas été facile pour vous
non non non non non non non non non à
vous savez j'ai toujours appris une
chose d un âge précoce reste rester
soi-même en permanence c'était des gens
fête le vin sans bouquet offert je pense
que nous
enfin pour la musique et surtout les
épis tous en particulier j'étais un
grand fan
les rues de la capitale saison écrit des
choses fabuleuses des beatles vous avez
repris elena rugby faisait opérer
yesterday john lennon vous avez repris
imagine en revanche il est beaucoup
moins - fans beaucoup moins fan du rap
et vous dit en parlant du rap inciter au
meurtre des flics en insultant sa mère
c'est immonde et même la ségrégation
raciale n'a jamais suscité de telles
chansons étaient franches et c'est ce
qui est malheureux la vie à toi parce
qu'il faut commencer à paris les
sociétés qui fabriquent des lycées sont
ces personnes à qui l'on s'est produit
mais pour moi n'a jamais fait dû être
quelque chose de cet être quelque chose
et plein d'amour est quelque chose que
je demande à voir comment la musique
peut être fondée pour quelques insultes
sa mère traite de [__] à [__] il
comprend pas à mon avis cela n'a pas de
place dans la musique
un point c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
alors la chance vous avez eu des petits
problèmes avec la drogue un vous avez
été arrêté en 1961 et puis après en 1962
en possession d'héroïne et vous avez
déclaré je me drogue depuis l'âge de 16
ans ne croyez pas que j'aime ce genre de
saloperie mais j'en ai besoin
ensuite j'ai fait une cure de
désintoxication et vous avez arrêté la
drogue depuis cette époque
est ce que vous avez vraiment arrêté
mardi suivi jeudi
quoique question intéressante au niveau
d'un match lorsque je ne suis pas sur ce
site on peut parler rebih moi je suis
très très spécifiques
quand vous affrontez se fait arrêter
arrêter quoi est fait aux mines
et si vous dit vous voulez dire qu'on
fume du cannabis ici tout le monde fume
pas et ne vous en faites pas
la smera blâme y en a mais est ok a los
angeles votre bureau est un immeuble
sans fenêtre et dans à l'inter de cet
immeuble
on doit rien touché parce que vous savez
exactement où chaque chose se trouve
c'est à dire que vous avez un petit peu
la vision au bout des doigts voyez
jeanne cherhal conçu desjoyeaux donc je
sais se trouvait et bien sûr j'ai mis
tout ça qui est bien l'intérieur
l'intérieur tant que c'est naturellement
ou tout ce qu'on veut parce que c'est
sélective et donc c'est très facile mais
j'ai fait ce mois pour vivre
alors votre force effectivement c'est
cette vision au bout des doigts et aussi
vos oreilles votre wii on vous appelle
bayonne ic ir ce qui veut dire l'oreille
bionique
vous avez l'oreille absolue et vous
dites mes oreilles me 10 99 % de ce que
je dois savoir sur ce qui m'entoure et
c'est pour ça que vous financez des
associations qui s'occupent de d'opérer
les oreilles ça à ma femme d'avis j'ai
fondu et c'est que nous faisons un diu
c'est mettre en place des implantations
mer ou des enfants qui n'ont jamais rien
entendu de leur fille bien merci ray
vous avez une question à poser à ray
charles sylvain attal non il faudrait
juste dire à quel point je suis ému de
le voir 2 je trouve que c'est là la
grande classe mais
c'est un signal
à tahiti à taishan
maintenant oreilles le pire est à venir
le pire est à venir nous allons faire et
mystérieux à tan dung
[Applaudissements]
la chasse que préférez vous en vous oh
voilà ce que je préfère la vision de
pouvoir fait atteindre mais je préfère
la perfection on peut jamais évoqué je
devrais peut être jamais faim c'est ce
que je préfère moi avons pensé que je
pouvais être au milan ac à tout moment
café voilà qu'est ce que vous détestez
en vous au nom de la race sais pas s'il
ya quelque chose dans ma vie honnêtement
je dirais que j'ai testé cette chose
parce que j'ai appris à surmonter un mot
la plupart des choses qui pose un
problème pour moi
ouais qu'est ce que vous préférez dans
la musique
or alive l'homme à la fia j'aime tous
les types de musique au lieu de deux il
suffit d'écouter
vous savez que plus je pouvais voir qu
apprécier les différents a dit la
république je n'ai jamais jamais jamais
rencontré quelqu'un
l'heure des braves gens qui n'aiment pas
ça ceci dit si comme moi music et hi fi
donc je pense qu'avant tout les ai vu
insulter personne mais je pense que la
musique c'est le plus grand des hasards
c'est le plus universel en tous les cas
des causes il y aura besoin de
traduction dans la musique il donne ni
translate les mieux et qu'est ce que
vous n'aimez pas dans la musique et je
veux y est justement d'accord on en a
parlé c'est parce que la seule chose que
je n'aime pas trop
musique danse et la musique
avec karine icher des [__] mais déjà
pas si tout est à l'uci qui comporte un
sentiment qui est un symbole mais je
n'aime pas des choses sales dans la
musique raï chose qu'elle a été le plus
grand moment de votre vie aux
marionnettes aux mondieux du nord a même
cédé je ne suis pas sûr de l'avoir
répondre à cette question parce que j'ai
eu à trop de belles choses dans ma vie
je ne pense pas pouvoir je suis moins de
choisir une chose et voilà
mais la chose la plus grande
peut-être la chose la plus grande car
est arrivé c'est lorsque j'ai joué pour
la preuve d'un fort accent allemand le
pire moment de votre vie vous savez dit
tout à l'heure je venais quand j'ai
tourné avec steria grâce à des que
j'habitais en floride je pouvais dormir
à l'extérieur et où à l'époque où je
n'avais rien à manger où il fallait
survivre
peut-être avec un [__] c'est que des
sorties de vacances appétit je dirais
pires moments de ma vie et je dois dire
parce que c'était la mode est de ma mère
c'était le moment le plus largement je
mets les plus dramatiques malades dont
j'ai eu un problème mais je pense que la
mort de ma mère c'était de pire qu'elle
était riche à ce votre plus belle
histoire d'amour
non non pas par un singe n'en sais rien
j'étais heureux de faire ce que je fais
et lorsque je le faisais sans voyez ce
que je veux dire
et votre plus minables histoire d'amour
votre pire histoire d'amour certaines
agences se séparent et je ne crois pas
que j'aie jamais eu quelque chose de ce
genre
ma vie ne s'est pas déroulée comme ça
vraiment dernière question est chose que
préférez-vous dans le sexe là je sais
pas si j'ai une préférence pour sa fille
non j'ai tiré tout simplement faux nez
régence
piaf
ça paraît
merci merci
si beaucoup merci jean pierre gross
merci pour votre aide
ouais merci à toi ce week-end
ah bon
[Applaudissements]
alors il aider merci vous allez partir
vous aussi
pendant votre train voilà et merci
beaucoup pour ce moment que nous faisons
passer je suis bouleversée de 2,2 tout
cela de tout ce qui vient de se passer
un personnage magnifique résidence merci
bernard bernard henri lévy réflexion sur
la guerre
cb
des dalles et de la guerre
carrément méchant jamais
à
mon méchant jamais content voici géant
meilleur
à
aujourd'hui que l'excès serge lama et
connaissait yvan attal vous avez vu son
film faut aller voir son fils je n'ai vu
et je le dis plein de bien pleins de
bien chez ruquier absolue et vous avez
raison c'est un film excellent je
recommande encore une fois j'aime bien
ici mois sur tous les plateaux et du
bien ça c'est vrai à tout le monde dit
du bien de ce film c'est vrai et noémie
lenoir donc écouter j'avais deux
objectifs dans la vie voir le film d'
yvan attal
je n'ai réussi et rencontres et noémie
lenoir pour déjeuner avec elle elle a
quitté new york pour s'installer à paris
donc maintenant tout est possible donc
jean millaire vous êtes psychanalyste
docteur en sciences politiques
prof de philo je dis ça parce que quand
même c'est bien prof de philo à
l'université paris 8
un fait de la radio vous fait de la télé
vous êtes aussi auteur il vous publié
chez stock un livre qui s'appelle
minoritaires vous savez comment on fait
pour la première fois et pour ma fille
coralie qui m'a dit papa cette fois
vraiment c'est pas son intérêt en fait
le jeu n'est fait pour elle d'être vie
plenel qui fait ça avec le point comme
ça il ya marc edouard nabe qui fait je
le ferai jamais enfin on peut un peu
accommoder votre livre minoritaire c'est
une façon de vous exprimer au delà de ce
que vous appelez le fury bons
professionnels des médias c'est que vous
êtes quelqu'un m'a appelé un jour dans
un journal j'ai trouvé ça marrant et
gelé repris oui oui mais sortir de cette
image qu'on montre et non de ça ça me va
bien être le contestataire attitré de la
télévision ces paroles désagréables un
taux il ya peut-être d'autres
explications à donner c'est ce que j'ai
voulu faire tout à fait alors vous
revenez sur votre parcours intellectuel
depuis le cours élémentaire 2 jusqu'à la
télé en passant par le maoïsme et la
psychanalyse et vous dit effectivement
j'aurais pu écrire en exergue
on a toujours raison de se révolter mais
oui a changé alors votre esprit de
contestation commence à la première
rédaction vous décidé de raconter une
histoire à dormir debout et l'écrire
comme s'il était vrai et ça vous procure
immédiatement les félicitations et les
considérations de non seulement du prof
mais de toute la classe
est-ce que ça s'applique à ce livre je
me suis demandé ça je me suis dit
tellement malin gérard muller que comme
sa première rédaction
il a écrit n'importe quoi mais très bien
et tout le monde a dit c'est génial
est ce que dans ce bouquin vous dites la
vérité toute la vérité j'ai appelé ça
une fiction autobiographique serre que
j'ai je dis la vérité sans m'attacher à
chaque détail mais qu'il faut retenir
c'est que ma première rédaction pipeauté
qui m'avait valu une très bonne note et
la considération de mes compagnons de
classe m'avait très embarrassé je me dis
mais comment c'est possible il suffit de
dire quelques phrases un petit peu bien
tourner aussitôt les gens sont là
fasciné je vous écoute et à vous croire
ça m'a servi de leçon
alors quand vous créer cette association
ce formidable il a créé une association
de défense des personnages de fiction
serre qui s'est aperçu que dans les
romans y avait des gens qui étaient très
mal traités
avec deux copains de place vous créer
une association de défense des
personnages de fiction c'est vrai ça
extraordinaire et notre idée c'était de
réécrire un certain nombre d'histoires
on avait commencé par la plus simple qui
était la petite marchande d'allumettes
pour prouver que cet état indigne que
cette petite fille est aussi froid
qu'elle ne vendent pas une seule
allumette qu'elle finisse par mourir et
donc on avait changé la météo il faisait
déjà mes meilleurs temps à noël on avait
proposé aux gens de s'arrêter au
contraire pour acheter ses allumettes
évidemment n'était pas très bon écrivain
on était plutôt idéaliste et un jour
vous découvrez que jean paul sartre
avait écrit la même chose exactement
parce que j'en ai lu sartre avec un
salaire mauriac valeur un diamant à
mauriac écoutez c'est pas comme ça qu'on
écrit des romans vous n'avez pas le
droit d'être aussi dictatorial avec vos
personnages ils doivent avoir une
certaine liberté je découvrais
finalement ses idées farfelues d'enfance
et ben ça les reprenait pour défendre la
liberté dans le roman donc vous étiez
satria avant de connaître ça voilà déjà
il y avait tout à fait un futur qui se
dessine est là alors le scoop du livre
c'est que vous savez hypnotisé faites
gaffe ou un jour un jour un jour gérard
muller tombe sur le manuel de l'étudiant
magnétiseur dans un grenier et vous
essayez avec votre petit copain nicolas
et ça marche et vous parvenez encore
mieux à faire oublier son prénom un
miranda qui était la plus jolie fille de
la classe
alors ça c'est absolument exact je n'ai
jamais pratiquer l'hypnose je le précise
toujours avec des patients puisque la
psychanalyse à abandonner définitivement
l'hypnose et je ne conseille à personne
de pratiquer l'hypnose pour des raisons
thérapeutiques mais il n'y a rien de
plus passionnant de voir des expériences
d'hypnose et de voir la facilité avec
laquelle on peut en quelques instants
paralyser un bras donner à quelqu'un le
sentiment de voler ou d'autres choses
tout aussi étonnante a priori lorsqu'on
pratique et queneau et j'ai souvent fait
à l'université un cours sur ce qu'on
appelle la généalogie d'un psychanalyste
et à la naissance un petit peu la
psychanalyse marco messmer charcot en
effet et
jeunes ont trait aux étudiants comment
on ya chez chacun de nous une sorte de
suggestibilité à fleur de peau et quand
quelques instants on arrive à provoquer
des effets de suggestions absolue ouais
vous pouvez provoquer quoi comme comme
les fais pas ce que je décris dans le
livre c'est à dire les effets les plus
simples sont en effet des paralysies des
sentiments de par exemple de boire de
l'eau quand on n'a strictement rien dans
la bouche nez dans la main et sentiment
très étrange ce qui fascine et freud et
c'est ce que je raconte dans un livre
c'est ce qu'on appelle les suggestions
post hypnotique c'est vous hypnotiser
quelqu'un est sous hypnose voulu dire
dans une heure dans deux heures ou dans
trois heures peut-être éventuellement
plus moi je les fais au maximum sur
trois heures à un moment donné quand je
dirais le mot champignons vous aurez
l'envi de vous asseoir par terre où que
vous soyez et deux heures trois heures
plus tard lorsque vous prononcez le mot
champignons je prends cet exemple là la
personne ressent irrésistiblement l'
envie de faire ça et ça fascine et freux
de savoir pourquoi quelque chose qu'on
mettait en finalement dans l'esprit à un
moment donné pouvait régis leurs comme
ça tu avais french doctor comme les
médicaments sans l'effet retard
exactement
et ça a bouleversé la conception qu'on a
du cartésianisme puisqu'en général dans
le cartésianisme indiquant la cause
cesse les fesses s est là la cause n'est
plus là et pourtant il ya un effet qui
continue et j'ai fait un certain nombre
d'expériences post hypnotique comme ça
qui sont assez intéressants
oui un sens que c'est sa mère et de la
réunion nationale car c'est très
rationaliste l'hypnose vous en faites
encore un sérieusement j'en fais
absolument pas pour des raisons
thérapeutiques je voulais dis-je en fait
lorsqu'on me demande plutôt amicalement
laurent ruquier par exemple lorsqu'on
était on part souvent en vacances les
uns avec les autres
je crois je peux le dire parce que on
connaît sophie forte qui est une
chanteuse brillante comédienne brillante
et sophie je l'avais notamment hypnotisé
devant laurent et devant tous les
copains qui étaient là ce jour là vous
avez fait quoi après tout bien tout
honneur
myriam bec donc à 16 ans vont rentrer
dans les jeunesses communistes et
rapidement viré dissidents mais c'est
normal vous êtes un dissident nez et
vous choisissez la dissidence chinoise
et vous dites d'ailleurs assez joliment
hérétiques avant même d'avoir été
orthodoxe alors voilà vous précisez bien
vous étiez maoïstes et pas trotskiste
ce que le maryse musset un peu plus olé
olé vous dites quest un peu plus
rock'n'roll série gauchistes sympa les
maristes ce qu'elle j'appartenais
n'étaient pas les plus drôles ils
avaient encore des plus drôles que nous
mais c'est vrai qu'on n'était pas comme
et crottes ski c'est à dire qu'on
n'avait pas l'idée qu'on était une
avant-garde qu'on allait construire un
monde meilleur on était vraiment anti
autoritaire et si on se réclamait de mao
il faut peut-être le préciser ce n'était
pas parce qu'on était fasciné par la
trique chinoise ou par les méthodes du
gouvernement chinois
c'est parce qu'il nous semblait qui
avait rien de plus révolutionnaire à
l'époque que de se réclamer de la chine
est donc dans le mouse est une façon
d'être le plus extrémiste possible et
c'est vrai qu'on était assez violent
on a mené des actions violentes mais
c'était toujours des actions plutôt
symbolique que des actions jamais on a
mis une bombe
jamais on a tiré sur ses haltères ou
quoi que ce soit de ce genre là en fait
vous agissiez le petit livre rouge
devant la les bourgeois comme un chiffon
rouge devant un taureau c'est ce que
vous dites
alors évidemment distribution de tickets
de métro gratuit c'est un relais est
ensuite distribuée à la population sympa
redistribution des produits de chez
fauchon aussi restée célèbre dans
l'histoire et vous dites on recevait
jamais d'or de pékin
ça c'est important à préciser parce que
incontestablement dans l'histoire du
parti communiste français les liens avec
moscou étaient très étroit il y avait
des agents de moscou qui venait donner
des ordres à paris il y avait de
l'argent qui circulait et nous je peux
dire que l'immense majorité des maoïstes
ont jamais rencontré un seul chinois de
leurs grains et donc c'est on n'était
pas du tout dans une relation je n'ai
jamais vu un ordre de pékin ou quoi que
ce soit sur nous a fait tordre de rire
et les chinois d'ailleurs avait autre
chose à faire que nous donner des
consignes j'attends de vous êtes quand
même avec deux fois de suite à
l'ambassade le chai de croix pourquoi
l'arche est allé une fois pour prendre
le thé ouais parce qu'on voulait
rencontrer je faisais partie d'une
association franco chinoises d'amitié
donc je lui avais une fois prendre le
thé avec le chinois et parlait plutôt de
la pluie et du beau temps et la deuxième
fois ça c'était plus politique c'était
en plein mai 68 j'accompagnais à
l'époque le dirigeant maoïste de
l'époque qui voulait explique aux
chinois qu'ils n'avaient rien compris à
la situation locale qui les a engueulé
pendant deux heures et les chinois ont
noté pendant deux heures les
récriminations de ces foules comme est à
la fois très sérieuse c'est à dire que
le gauchisme en général pas seulement le
maoïsme y compris le trotskisme les
anars et d'autres ont quand même
coup changer cette société moi je suis
toujours indigné quand on oublie que mai
68 et ce qui a suivi sur toutes les
années 70 ont contribué à ce qu'on soit
aujourd'hui plus en liberté et quand je
dis contribuer c'est à dire c'est pas
nous qui avons fabriqué ça mais ce que
vous imaginez simplement et les gens qui
ont 20 ans aujourd'hui que mai 68 et
notamment partie parce que les garçons
ne pouvait pas aller dans les dortoirs
et à la fac
celle qu on ne pouvait pas mettre une
affiche dans une fac sont sereins cogner
et qu'à l'époque dès que vous aviez
envie de protester il y avait un flic
qui étaient là pour vous frapper qui
avait aucune liberté hier vous avez
raison c'est à la radio à la télé le
mois de juillet simplement de chanter
les louanges du général de gaulle enfin
il faut se souvenir de ce que c'était du
temps du général de gaulle quand même
avec la mairie bonne et tout ça c'était
pas rigolo rappelons puisqu'on est à la
télé qu'à l'époque du général de gaulle
le présentateur du journal avait son
téléphone directement relié au ministre
de la formation qui lui disait alors
quels sont les titres du soir donc
c'était une situation bouclée quand nous
avions 20 ans qui n'a rien à voir la
france d'aujourd'hui sous chirac comme à
l'époque sous mitterrand est infiniment
plus démocratique ça n'a rien à voir
avec ce que nous on a connu alors
ensuite vous vous établissez comme on
disait à l'époque si vous devenez
ouvriers agricoles je m'imagine je vous
vois ouvrier agricole dans l'affairé
porsche est en train de laver leur
expliquer aux masses paysannes
comment se révolter mais les masses
paysannes comme vous dites elles étaient
tout à fait six mois j'ai fait plus
d'action presque avec des paysans contre
des cumulards comme on disait c'est des
gens qui se débrouillaient pour avoir
planté alors qu'il n'en avait pas le
droit que dans les villes oui vous
faisiez par exemple libériez les chevaux
de course d'un riche propriétaire
c'était des actions de l'époque
et alors le mec sort sur son perron avec
son fusil comme ça et là d'un seul coup
vous voyez voilà à quoi il a perdu le
pouvoir et sait plus où il en est et où
fait beaucoup rire c'était plutôt drôle
enfin ils peuvent aussi tirer parce que
c'est une période où le temps en temps
ça ça tirait de l'autre côté pas de
l'autre mais faut pas oublier par
exemple je dédie ce livre notamment à
deux de mes copains gilts un pierre
overney qui ont été tués l'un précipitée
par une charge policière non lors 68 et
l'autre en 72 flinguer à bout portant
par un vigile de renom dans la régie
renault à cette affaire alors quand même
toujours beaucoup d'humour parce que
votre chien s'appelait iéna nké la
localité où mao
a fait ces fameuses causerie sur l'art
et la littérature donc quand même
toujours
voilà c'est ça quand même qu'il y avait
toujours son vin peut vous sauver un peu
oui c'est bien alors vous rentrer à
paris
et là vous vous lancez dans la
psychanalyse je me suis retrouvé plus
tôt en l'air après la vie que vous avez
un peu évoqué j'étais plutôt paumé de
revenir à paris deux ans notamment
d'ouvriers agricoles j'étais j'avais
fait normale sup
je me retrouvais après dans les
campagnes c'était pas évident à paris
donc j'ai commencé une analyse et j'ai
découvert une pratique qui m'a tirée
d'affaires d'abord moi même et qui me
semble toujours jusqu'à ce jour une des
pratiques les plus précieuses que nous
avons à notre disposition et après vous
parlez de la tv il ya des pages
savoureuses sur la télé notamment une
phrase que j'ai que j'ai noté sur
l'inutilité de la parole vous dit vous
avez aligné plusieurs phrases sans
provoquer un éclat de rire ou une
émotion de pacotille dans la régie sa
grimace et sa coupe
gentiment sans éclat sans volonté
consciente de censure mais sa coupe
c'est la loi du genre c'est bien vous
avez bien compris et vous savez bien que
c'est exactement comme ça c'est souvent
les gens qui ne sont pas du tout à la
télé on a l'impression qu'on est très
machiavélique quand on travaille un
éléphant général produites tout c'est
des gens simplement tu sont là pour le
sentiment qu'ils font un peu raccourcir
comme par hasard c'est le moment vous
avez développé un certain nombre de
thèses qui pourrait choquer tel ou tel
mais s'est fait sans méchanceté c'est
pas l'époque justement de gaulle
pompidou où on est moi ce que je trouve
le plus habile à la télévision je vais
vous dire vous le faites vous même un
petit peu c'est pas vous qui le faites
le plus c'est d'inviter beaucoup de gens
même temps mais vous vous le savez là
quand même le talent de laisser les gens
parler
mais si l'on vous invite 15 personnes
sur un plateau il y à peine vous avez
commencé à parler que vous avez déjà
empêché 14 autres personnes plus allez
on vous dit attendez attendez il veut
parler nuit et du coup c'est pas la télé
qui vous empêche de parler c'est votre
voisin c'est à dire vous même et quand
on vous dit mais nous on vous aurez bien
laisser parler mais vous avez vu il
fallait laisser parler les eaux de la
télé
c'est très bien vu à vous parler des
animateurs de téné 8 qui sont incapables
de se libérer des prompteurs et les
oreillettes inventé pour les domestiques
et quand même oui pourquoi ça c'est pas
les deux michel domestique et le mot est
violent et vous n'êtes pas le plus visé
vous êtes un peu visé aussi mais pas le
plus c'est pas pour ça que j'ai pas de
la sympathie pour la télé oui bah oui je
sais je suis je suis plutôt content d'y
être mais c'est vrai que je voulais dire
vraiment ce que je pense de la télé cela
allait passer mais autour du pot on me
dit dans l'oreillette que cette partie
d'une interview est terminée je suis
désolé jerram hiver
non
stone ya un truc qui s'il ya un truc
le bouquin s'appelle minoritaires bon
vous êtes pas tellement minoritaire
quand même moi je me pense comme tel
c'est à dire que qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un majoritaire et je respecte la
majorité puisque la démocrate il faut
bien été et donc la majorité doit être
représentée mais un minoritaire c'est
quelqu'un qui n'a pas le sentiment qu'il
doit plaire au plus grand nombre
d'accords enfin et non ce ne sont pas
vos idées sont pas minoritaire décidé
que vous défendez quand certaines leçons
là tu me considère même que la
psychanalyse et tolérant vous êtes de
gauche pour la démocratie
c'est des choses qui sont couramment
admise quand même je suis un peu plus à
gauche qu'un bon nombre de gens de
gauche je ne suis pas d'une tolérance
fall par exemple j'ai fait scandale dans
une émission que vous même produisiez si
je ne me trompe en explique koko n'étant
pas journaliste n'étant pas aux
politiques je considérais qu'il y avait
des gens avec qui je ne devais pas
parler moi elle m'a dit comment c'est
pas bien vous devez parler avec tout le
monde est non moi je considère que tout
le monde a le droit la parole que tout
le monde bien évidemment pu publier
écrire et vivre sa vie mais que moi
comme citoyen il ya des gens avec qui je
n'ai pas à parler on m'a dit vous êtes
un tonnerre pour pas mal votre frère
jacques alain miller que vous aimez
beaucoup beaucoup parce qu'il vous a
beaucoup aidé dans la vie mais parce que
c'est un type formidable
voilà quand il écrit dans la tendresse
des terroristes le bourreau terroriste
est un enfant de choeur hun sen de
vitrail un ange pressés de se dépouiller
de son corps un idéaliste un fou pas une
canaille
il est beaucoup plus minoritaires que
vous là sur le coup votre frère met
l'accent dans un très beau texte est
évidemment que vous lisez comme s'il
faisait l'apologie de quelque chose qui
est absolument sûr le risque de la
pureté met l'accent sur le fait qu'il
faut se méfier des purées d'être au pur
et qu'on a vu ce que ça donnait y
compris dans la révolution française
quand les gens étaient incorruptible et
il dit avec beaucoup d'humour que nous
qui nous plaignons à juste titre que nos
hommes politiques parfois ont la main
peu l'est du côté de la caisse ou vont
coucher à droite et à gauche il dit mais
peut-être que c'est pas si mal parce
qu'au moins ils n'ont pas l'idée d'être
aussi pure que le sont par exemple et
barbare qui sont allés flinguer les les
tours new yorkaises et donc il fait un
texte sur le fait qu'il faut bien
comprendre que derrière tout
l'exaltation de la pureté
il ya toujours un risque profond je
trouve ça assez juste vrai nous avons
bien votre frère web il m'a en grande
partie
mais je sais bien sûr considère je lui
dois beaucoup
comme beaucoup d'anciens trotskistes ou
d'anciens maoïste vous êtes pro
américain bien sûr aujourd'hui oui tout
est juste considère comme ayant
suffisamment manifester contre
l'impérialisme américain et toujours
prêt à le céder à bon port et alenty à
la mondialisation et donc à être anti
mondialiste qu'aujourd'hui j'ai pas eu
la moindre hésitation moi je n'aime pas
au moment où les tours sont touchés
comme elles le sont je n'aime pas les
gens qui disent bouche bien sûr ça n'est
pas bien là de ben laden ça dépend ne
peut pas les renvoyer dos à dos il ya un
moment que ça il ya avec la guinée qui
dit les américains n'ont que ce qu'ils
méritent
je trouve ça monstrueux c'est il faut
dire les termes donc rester à l'extrême
gauche je sais pas vous mais moi je me
considère tout à fait comme étant de
gauche plus ou moins qu'à rétablir je ne
sais pas mais je me souviens en tout cas
qui avait un certain nombre de gens qui
disaient plutôt hitler que
la guerre plutôt ne pas choisir entre
les américains que les nazis et ya des
moments où vous êtes obligés de faire
des choix qui ne vous plaît c'est ce
qu'envisage moi ça ne me plaît pas ce
choix là et je le fais sans hésitation
17h15 et les villas phrase de malraux
faire la guerre sans l'aimer
ça c'est la moindre des choses mais en
plus faire la guerre à l'occasion avec
des gens qu'on aime pas malheureusement
et c'est vrai que je n'ai pas de
sympathie du tout pour bush et que je
n'ai pas envie de nuancer sa vie je suis
chef de bouche aujourd'hui savez c'est
comme disait le général de gaulle moi
qui ne suis pas devenu gaulliste après
l'avoir tellement combattu quand j'ai un
étudiant de gold et à juste titre que
les américains on est souvent séparés
quand ça va bien et qu'on se rapproche
d'eux quand ça va mal et bien lâche
considère que ça va mal et que c'est
tout à fait important notamment quand on
est contre l'impérialisme américain de
savoir choisir son camp à certains
moments et moi je les choisis mais sans
hésiter vous n'êtes pas minoritaires non
plus aux couleurs sur ce coup là pas du
tout dieu merci
messieurs c'est chez stock
jr vous savez à quoi vous allez avoir
droit là je suis prêt il intervient
aussi repompe mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
voilà ce qu'a donné 68000 air voilà hier
qu'ils sont tous bas fils maintenant
voynet il bouge pas mal jingle germi
l'air vous effectué un parcours sans
faute une carrière impeccable que
pouvez-vous faire de mieux
qu'est ce que je pouvais faire de mieux
sans doute c'est aller travailler avec
des gens avec qui je n'ai vraiment pas
envie de travailler parce que jusqu'à
présent j'ai réussi à travailler avec
des gens très variés dont je n'aurais
jamais pensé me rapprocher peut-être que
je peux aller encore faire mieux et
qu'un jour vous verrez je ne sais pas
avec la gaffe ou avec les animateurs
jean pierre pernaut est ce que vous êtes
conscient de votre charisme hors du
commun
oui mais vous ne mesurez pas à quel
point lorsque je suis par exemple à côté
noémie je me sens petit du point de vue
de l'analyse mais à chaque seconde
depuis que je suis là je ne sais pas
combien de minutes ça va lui plaire
il est très joueur miller vous est
incroyablement sexy commencer
l'interview cher pompe
comment résister vous aux sollicitations
féminine cga un premier critère c'est
que notamment toutes les lettres d'amour
très nombreuses que je reçois je ne sais
pas combien vous en recevez vous même
enfin revu plusieurs centaines comme moi
par semaine toutes les lettres d'amour
d'abord je les classe par ordre
alphabétique et je ne les lis qu'une
fois dans l'année c'est assez frappant
donc à ce moment là beaucoup des
passions qui sont déchaînés sont
certainement grave il est donc je
réussis que ça me débarrasser d'un grand
nombre de soupirs hantz et c'est très
agréable de mentir à ce point
accessible les cheveux vous faites ça
dans votre bouquin de germes hiver tout
paris bruisse de vos exploits
on dit que vous êtes un super coup est
ce que c'est vrai je trouve profondément
vexant ce que vous dites d'évoquer mes
supers coups simplement d'en parler
[Applaudissements]
une question qui va intéresser tous nos
téléspectateurs maintenant gérard muller
comment faites vous pour avoir toujours
raison
alors même quand j'ai tort je vais vous
dire ça sérieusement c'est que même
quand j'ai tort je me dis si je le
reconnais ça ne compliquera la vie et du
coup je reste fidèle à ce que j'ai dit
avant
j'ai toujours le sentiment que
aujourd'hui on n'a pas plus raison qui
est vrai les gens ont toujours le
sentiment qu'il faut faire des
autocritiques moi je ne suis pas bon
pour les autocritiques je le reconnais
et dans l'ensemble je me trompe pas plus
que les autres en moyenne en moyenne
gérard miller vous est peu à peu devenu
indispensable
onfray commençant vous il ya quelqu'un
qui arrive derrière ce qu'ils gardent je
ne vis pas de rire ce qui gâche tout
parce qu'il ya un truc que brice que ses
clips noces et que la première question
je me dise ou de ma gueule la deuxième
jeudi mais peut-être est-il sérieux et à
la troisième je suis convaincu qu'une
vraie dans l'alizé on est à la sixième
ou la septième du genre mieux avoue est
peu à peu devenu indispensable onfray
comment sans vous on peut coûter
il ya un moment donné où je pense qu'il
faut partir du principe que si je
n'étais pas là personne ne pourrait me
remplacer je crois
ses gestes
m
bien quelques e-mails avant de
poursuivre beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup du
mail sur hélène ségara parce que vous
savez gérard que orlando le producteur
d'hélène ségara ne veut pas qu hélène
viennent dans l'émission donc jean
françois lanoue de lille dit orlando qui
interdit tout le monde en parle à m
segarra c'est un taliban allégeance en
france bardot de musique qui veut créer
le comité de libération d'hélène ségara
j'imagine que vous ignorez volontiers la
pétition dans je ne signe jamais de
pétitions j'en ai tellement fait signer
je ne signe pas alors beaucoup du mail
pour thalia hausse italia et issia bien
évidemment talia ne respecte pas le
principe quand il ya soufflage il ya des
habillages c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'elle
souffre sens déshabiller
systématiquement alors certains
suggèrent qu'elle vienne nu et qu'elle
sera be quand elle souffle alors
évidemment d'autres suggèrent de mettre
un lien aux enchères pour sauver michel
blanc mais ça nous ne le ferons pas ce
n'est pas le genre de la maison
alors concernant michael blanc justement
très intéressant michaël blanc où
celui-ci ce garçon quitte à ben ali qui
était condamné à perpétuité pour du h
c'est énorme mais jusqu'à la fin de ses
jours il a enfermé là bas donc on essaye
de le faire sortir
ça commence à avancer alors le 7 d'or
mons est d'or qui est là c'est d'ordre
la caissière émission musicale très
lourd qui était sincère donc il ya
monsieur marc bourret qui propose cent
mille francs
[Applaudissements]
exemple je pense qu'il y en a
merci monsieur marc moret le hot d'or le
hot d'or soixante mille balles voilà a
été proposé le soutien gorge de kalia
parce que tes amis son soutien gorge aux
enchères dix mille balles évidemment
mais ça aurait rapporté plus mais non
c'est du caca
donc ça fait quand même 170 mille francs
pour ces trois objets plus 115 mille
francs de dons directs ça fait 285 mille
francs pour michaël blanc merci beaucoup
nous avons su de guitare est ce que la
guitare et la médine
nous avons une guitare aussi qui est
offerte par didier barbelivien venez
méline je vais montrer la guitare nous
la mettons aux enchères à partir
d'aujourd'hui c'est un peu comme un vide
greniers voilà la guitare voilà alors
bien fait des offres faites des enchères
et puis c'est une très belle guitare
vous pouvez avoir chez vous si vous
cotisez pour michel blanc et c'est non
seulement pour michel blanc pour la
caution mais aussi pour la mère de
michel blanc qui est obligé de vivre à
bali et c'est pour ça que disait
barbelivien envoyé cette guitare parce
que tout le monde pense à ça c'est que
la mère vit là bas
et effectivement il faut bien qu'elle
puisse bouffer là bas ils n'ont pas
beaucoup d'argent ces gens là alors la
meilleure nouvelle est à venir c'est que
le président chirac a décidé de suivre
la faire merci jacques
en fait
vers 10 heures si chirac ed a libéré
michaël blanc tenté de voter pour lui
quand même non non ça ne suffit pas j'ai
déjeuné avec lui quelques jours et son
épouse avec michel drucker et toute
l'équipe
donc c'est un quelqu'un que je suis ravi
de fréquenter l occasion est votée cette
autre chose non je vais vous dire si il
s'occupe de ce cas là et de quelques
autres à mon avis c'est je suis désolé
de dire comme ça la moindre des choses
on peut lui en être reconnaissant mais
c'est la moindre des choses qu'on a des
présences de chacun de ses concitoyens y
compris de ceux qui sont le plus dans la
mer voir notamment lequel sait bien
qu'il le fasse c'est très bien c'est
parfait
moi je dis merci jacques parce que je
sais que tu nous regardes en buvant
qu'un coroner
je sais je le sais bien
j'accueille maintenant le gie doigts
ah ah
dix doigts mesdames messieurs arnaud
bonsoir j'ai souhaité vous soyez là ce
soir parce que je crois que vous faites
un spectacle en ce moment qui est
formidable et qui nécessite un petit peu
de publicité un petit peu de promotion
un petit peu de bouche à oreille pour
devenir un des grands succès de l'hiver
à paris ça se passe déjà très vite ça se
passe très bien mais ça va être encore
mieux à exactement le sur la scène de la
comédie de paris
il s'appelle shakespeare défi avec eric
métayer arnaud gidoin et gil galliot ans
le pitch est simple ces trois acteurs
qui sont pas toujours au diapason et qui
vont tenter l'impossible c'est à dire
jouer 37 pièces de shakespeare en 90
minutes on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
mal et aux serbes
ce soir nous allons vous présenter
devant mon jeu c'est paris n'ont pas dit
ce monstre est ce ce qui porterait
malheur mais bien c'est the comedy leçon
d'humilité je ferme bio toi tu fais tout
roule quelque soit la réponse juliette
juliette
ah non pas passif si tu aimes les
capulet a tenté ma cité avec un pull est
pas d'intérêt ni piatti il ya tellement
atteint et connait il sole et trento
matinaux j'aime à me lever grands tels
dell le soleil se lève aussi tôt le
matin n'est pas plus à plaindre des
textes je jouerai le rôle de duncan
leroy décosse est alors pour les 10
peut-être qu'on pourrait demander c'est
le début de la guerre de cent ans
eh bien bon soir il est 17h45 en direct
d'azincourt
vous pouvez sur cette carte henri sainte
d'angleterre est en passe de prendre le
dessus sur l'armée royale française je
suis comme un cochon sur la mère de mes
sentiments pour la
vous me direz le docteur william
shakespeare
tout est bien qu'il fit
[Musique]
ces experts des villes 37 pièces de
ces experts en 90 minutes avec arnaud
gidoin gil galliot et héritier voilà
énorme succès à londres
et ça va être un carton à paris a fait
cinq ans que ça se joue à londres voilà
c'est énorme
évidemment projet explique un peu nous
inviter les spectateurs c'est
shakespeare façon rap façon dj façon en
bande annonce d'un film hollywoodien
façon bateleur de cirque enfin et c'est
sur les bonimenteurs mais voilà c'est
vrai c'est très sympa c'est vrai que ce
qu'on a voulu rendre c'est que en fait
on s'amuse avec avec rien quoi et dans
ce spectacle ce qui est assez fabuleux
c'est qu'on a tous le premier rôle et
enfin il ya d'autres surprises qu'on
peut peut-être pas dévoiler ici mais
comme dans les pièces de shakespeare on
sait qu'il ya des hommes mais aussi des
femmes
oui c'est toujours un garçon par les
femmes ça tombe toujours sur vous et
voilà vous en faire la tête de turc du
spectacle s'est fait pousser la barbe
pour être sûr je vais essayer là c'est à
se tordre de rire
je ne savais pas que vous veniez ce soir
gérard hardy en fait même mardi dernier
mais c'est irrésistible qui ont des
coûts sur scène le côté les plus anciens
s'en souviennent pas les plus jeunes
qu'on appelle la pop in pour espérer
tenir sur celle ci on est écroulé de
rire pour un peu il ya des références
exactes
c'est simple a fait ce qu'on joue
vraiment les textes de l'enquêté
elle s'écrira non je trouve rire voir
cette pièce on a cherché aussi adapté
puisque le texte l'adaptation était très
anglo anglaise
donc on a vraiment c'est vraiment
beaucoup amusé à répétition pendant six
semaines à recréer un petit peu à la
française et notamment avec deux
comédiens donc gilles galliot et eric
métayer qui viennent de la ligue d'impro
on s'est vraiment mis dans le bain et on
fait beaucoup de détournements d'objets
et
beaucoup voyaient là c'est que c'est une
grosse éclatant c'est une glace alors
non on se connaît depuis longtemps oui
oui c'est beaucoup milité pour vous moi
aussi j'y arrive pas il est beau non pas
parce que vient d'arriver à paris la wii
alors oui quand ils manquent de tout
c'est tombé laisser tomber sans son
copain new yorkais oui j'ai appris ça
c'est cool je vais faire une association
de défense de nos élire et je ne
souhaite pas quelques membres du
sous-entendu oui je regarde on voulait
faire un truc comme on se connait je
peux pas parler de vous parce que je
vous connais trop bien je vous ai vu
dans toutes les situations
la république donc je sais lui une star
de télévision imaginé voilà noémie
arrive vous êtes tous les deux comment
vous vous raconte auriez qu'est ce que
vous diriez à noémie lenoir pour vous
raconter vous lui diriez quoi sergent
que baisser un peu la lumière s'il te
plaît parce que non je crois que je ne
vais me jean laville lui il ya plein de
choses
la bcl vous demandez qui es-tu arnaud
qui es-tu arnaud je suis un gars vont
découvrir mes amis ça marche pas si ceux
ci je t'emmènerai faire un petit toad en
masse en six saisons et jean porcher
miss aisne
je te raconterai plein de choses je te
mangerais sur une sur une plage non sa
chanteuse de charles aznavour est
grandement brouille pas avec ton en elle
oui merde ils commencèrent on connaît de
service - anelka moi mais c'est faux le
faut laisser un petit peu aux autres
16 c'est bien là bas 6 décembre j'avais
écrit ce cas là tu veux pas non plus à y
voir je veux pas que moi aussi je suis
lesbienne
thierry oui je veux bien mais qu'est ce
que je suis tellement beau non mais dis
moi on se connaissait ne se connaissent
pas et tu travailles ou toi moi ouais
écoutez là j'ai un petit truc dans le
11e à venir faire un petit tour et puis
on montre un petit peu les étages tu
serais souffle et et prendre un pot et
je te prendrai la bouche
bien
vision bien tapé un mur
non
moment
la city
k
patrice
merci concluait la semaine prochaine
j'en sais beaucoup
nature
sinon
on ne saura pas qu'arnaud jdois essayé
toutes sortes de métiers avant de faire
celui là et je suis content en tous les
cas pour toi parce que là ce coup là
c'est l'air de vraiment marché
maintenant on est vraiment ravi il ya un
super beau charest les gens viennent et
axor super avis on est vraiment contents
mais faut il y aller
ouais les soirs à 21h30 et voilà le
problème
[Applaudissements]
monsieur shakespeare débit
il faille attention maintenant on va
passer au blind test un blind test ce
soir qui en l'honneur de serge lama est
consacré au chanteur et aux chanteuses
qui porte le nom de ruby beau c'est une
idée de béatrice n'est pas moi voilà
donc des noms d'animaux
mais bien entendu pour arbitrer ce blind
test accompagné de ses deux juges de
touche
j'accueille en am au dessus de tout
soupçon mesure vélo bordier
[Applaudissements]
non
oh
sortie si les demoiselles bonsoir donc
on peut gagner l'équipe visana il ya
l'équipe des bananes ça me rappelle
steevy chez laurent ruquier
quand laurent a dit à stevie tu vois il
plane sur plateau tu vois tu n'es pas
venu pour rien bien voir alors d'abord
d'abord on va commencer avec un exigeant
pour que tout le monde comprenne bien
didier
[Musique]
je suis désolé certains jeux attention
didier dingle
bon tailleur mais bien d'accord s'il
vous plaît tiens soulager des habillages
ok ok les naissains attention donc les
gens qui chantent ont tous des noms
d'animaux serge lama didier
à bientôt
j'ai envie leur dit catherine barma et
même chose je mens je dis la même chose
attention didier les visuels
la dent noémie rien non mais les
scarabées ça joue à verdir la haine que
des chanteurs que le nombre d'animaux
oui serge lama ça c'est plus dur c'est
beaucoup plus
s'agace alias les chats perdus
voilà bravo bravo à mme gidoin on
continue encore animal didier
[Musique]
chauffage
ça chante 8 voilà voilà voilà ça serait
pas arrivé en 67 série je répète la
règle que des champions qui ont des noms
d'animaux lama voilà d'accord on
continue didier
oui bon
ou les
c'est un choix commun qu'une stratégie
aucune insécurité réelle des bayonnais
j'ai passé 5 sonia de paris
est-ce qu'ils ont d ailleurs bien sûr il
ya les vélib parisien géant mineurs
mettez vos bâillon mettez les bâtisses
plus je me crois chez moi les enfants
plus personne le pays s'était ainsi
gaston rue gaston un peu avec gilles
agniel j'anime elle cela mais qui te dit
tu es enfant s'appelle manon ninon et
gaston le quatrième fils devrait
l'appeler chichon on continue didier
[Musique]
ah ouais
les mêmes à deux points et les bananes
mais prend et ballades et bana attention
didier
[Musique]
je mets double champion
bravo arnaud donc ça fait 3 n en a
remonte à hendaye les bananes sont
toujours à quatre ça c'est très
compliqué ils n'avaient pas trouvé les
niveaux au niveau qui va je suis
tranquille peut-être resort à 50 balais
didier
[Musique]
woods a dit non et richesses
[Applaudissements]
voilà
et oui j'étais recueil s'agit big apple
je vous adore j'ai une passion pour vous
mais là franchement j'ai pas tricher on
me l'a pas dit soupçon russie elle a dit
me
je vous demande de vous arrêter pas le
poids ne compte pas mais l'attention
hu
le chien elle avait du bon sens yohann
diniz ne se fait pas
balade guidée après 80 mais ça fait rien
la culture c'est même avant oui bon
n'avait pas demandé non c'est pas
attention j'aime bien très très dur aux
4,4
encore plus dur ces points pour les
bananes au moins pour les annales
[Applaudissements]
10e
[Musique]
non
m
est ce qu'il est
la serbie sommet
pourquoi il me démerder
je devais valeur
mon père a souffert tous partout
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
cette année on va départager si pareille
soufflage si on peut faire un petit jeu
du rhône à la triche attention du public
attention tu m'envoies tombé à un plus
bas à tension s'est endettée attention
attention
mais attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
au fait
voilà
pour aller en continu didier
[Musique]
contrat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
non
non mais gagner oui alors il est génial
parce qu'il fait un carton au cinéma en
belgique et noblesse bonfim
tiens j'ai
on continue à temps
j'y crois plus gk par ici
oui
non
c'est panique à son époque
on connaîtra aujourd'hui oui mais
attention attention mesdames et
messieurs le super banco les ananas 4
les bananes 8 l'équipe
peut remporter le bundle je sais c'est
injuste mais la vie est un juge
attention je veux l'interprète d'illiez
et messieurs attention je vais vous
faire une chanson le sujet au nord sur
1990 c'est l'heure des communications
m
football
les mines
c'est semble
guirassy
[Applaudissements]
je dois intervenir il est effectivement
au soufflage ici
il abat l'un conduit là bas donc le
point est ici
[Applaudissements]
et vendredi séance de l'école des fans
en même temps bon tout le monde garde
yapi jacques martin ont fait cas de
l'école des fans viennent le soir
voilà bah écoute et merci
lamballe vite sexe magouille culture
générale de laurent baffie avec gambit
pascal sellem mas de morales daniel
russo et géraldine données guérin c'est
au gymnase et là monsieur yvan attal le
fisc yvan attal
la femme est une actrice de lointains
avec charlotte gainsbourg et yvan attal
tm sky est ce que vous avez sous les
yeux c'est la bande originale du film
vent bravo à gauche chère et rallye pour
vous noémie lenoir
non
[Applaudissements]
noir de lagence font qu'on retrouvera le
30 janvier n'ont astérix munich lui
changeait pas de la banane avec alain
chabat
kb litchi jarre depardieu et christian
clavier jamel debbouze hainaut
lenoir merci à bientôt
et entre en france serge lama lui
d'abord le single i quand est ce qu on
fait l'amour
le single et l'album taille à feuilles
l'album de charge la mab et les
messieurs faille à toi et moi
à l'olympia du 26 au 31 mai
là en ville est vide les versions sur la
guerre le mal et la fin de l'histoire
le tcd
d'années de la guerre et souchez brasser
merci damas d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir
jean charles brisard guillaume dasquié
ben laden la vérité interdite c'est chez
denoël
un livre très intéressant sur les deux
sites de la crise les cieux richards
règle
en concert le 26 novembre à paris au
palais des congrès le 27 novembre
danemark et le bas depuis neuf ans
à bruxelles c'est lausanne yb elle que
je salue ici géant miller minoritaires
ses stocks
évasion une paire ailleurs
arnaud gidoin j'expire le 10 mai
gil galliot à la comédie de paris tous
les soirs à 21h30
merci et philippe corti km n'ont pas ces
récits
voilà
c'était souvent par l'émission
du tout du tout du tout comme les autres
rendez vous
brochard merci de votre fidélité
non
à
[Musique]
no
jean nouvel
non
là
jamais non
[Musique]
non
l'eau
là
[Musique]
non
c'est que ça
[Musique]
jamais
dès maintenant
m
les babys mois
jusqu'où tu
j
[Musique]
un record
m
tiens
on
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu